so everything is coming down I hate to
be checking a little better bad news but
that's why on my tweet I was begging
people you gotta change your thinking
you know get rid of those that Mantra go
to school get a job work hard buy stocks
and bonds save cash three times Andy
scheckman on the smartest guy I know a
three times crash is coming first of all
all paper assets second real estate
third cash is trash I hope I'm wrong our
debt to GDP you know in 2008 wasn't that
bad then after when it crashed then
Bernanke started printing you know they
call it quantitative easing it's
printing money and so uh that's why in
2013 I wrote the book Rich dad's
prophecy to warn people that the crash
was going to get bigger in 2013 I wrote
that book and it's going to get bigger
because the debt the GDP David as most
people know is 130 debt to GDP it's the
biggest world history our debt is
through the roof and power is Raising
interest rates which makes that debt
more expensive hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I'm make these videos because as a
young entrepreneur I struggled to keep
my business going I had no friends I had
no mentors I had no role models and the
thing that saved me was learning from
the success stories of famous
entrepreneurs and in their stories I got
motivation and I also got strategies for
what I could do to grow my business and
not stay stuck and I still need their
stories for motivation today so today
let's learn from one of the best Robert
Kiyosaki and some of his amazing
inspiration enjoy
let me give some dates been in 1974 was
the deal was cut
that the world would have to buy oil in
U.S dollars
right and that's what Andy's talking
about is Dallas saying right now adios
dollars and Andy is saying 60 today of
the world's population will stop using
the US dollar
and that's what gives us power
so those of you who are saving those
fake dollars you're in serious trouble
right now
and that's why what Andy says and then
Kim will back me up for all these years
we don't save dollars
we save gold coins and silver coins
towards someplace else
because that is the challenge with gold
and silver as a storage
so I want you to understand this this
goes back to what they always say at
school go to school get a good job
work hard pay taxes and save money and
invest in the stock market
and that's what we're talking about now
that dollar gave us the power to the
stock market to go through the roof
and when they talk about the you know
the bubble the three times bubble it
stocks
paper assets real estate and the dollar
is going to crash so all you out there
Savers out there I would pay attention
right now because if you still think
you're still believing in the power of
the dollar you're in serious trouble
don't teach pigs to sing waste your time
it annoys the pig if you're talking to
pigs at home don't teach them to sing
because it's waste your time they still
believe in going to school getting a job
saving money paying taxes getting out of
debt and investing in a 401k or an IRA
they're going to be the biggest losers
today I mean it's already they've
already started to lose if you look at
the stock market and they're going to
try and incurb inflation but as you know
they're raising interest rates which is
not going to solve it's going to make it
worse
so if you really want a real education
you can go back to college giving
student loan debt and wonder what
happened to your life because you're
still saving money and investing in a
401k I mean that's the most stupid thing
you can do right now what would
Financial education in school look like
for you what would you like to have
learned well it's really simple because
my poor dad I finally bugged him enough
you know I said well what am I going to
learn about money is why don't you ask
your best friends father my classmate
and that was Mike in the book I had to
change his name for the family doesn't
want to be known and I said why does
Mike why does Mike's father know about
money my rich dad's My Poor Dad said
because he's an entrepreneur
I'm like what's that and what are you he
said I'm an employee I'm only nine years
old I'm learning two new words employee
and entrepreneur
come on what what's the difference you
know and then my poor dad says well an
entrepreneur must know about money an
entrepreneur must speak the language of
money
I want what
and then my poor dad says and what I
said what I use is I'm a school teacher
I'm an employee
and what about you why don't you have to
learn to speak to about money he says
because all I want is a paycheck and a
pension paychecks and pensions
so that's kind of the you know I'm nine
years old I am totally confused now
so I go across towns a little dinky
little sugar Plantation talent I said my
classmates owned the plantations and the
kids across the street at Union School
all union members
they worked for the plantations and
mother you know so I'm going I'm poor so
I sit down with my rich dad who never
went to school ironically
and um he wouldn't teach me about money
either and he kept rejecting me
I didn't realize it was part of the
process he wanted to find out how badly
I wanted to learn and he says and as we
all know as entrepreneurs right
salesmanship begins when the customer
says no and so the more he said no the
more I got into I said well
and so I kept you know going back to
talk to him and all he says get out of
here kid so that was test number one for
my Rich Dad test number two was as if if
I teach you you have to work for me for
free and I said why for free he says
because if I pay you you'll think like
you're dead or dead
the rich don't work for money so if
you've read Rich Dad Poor Dad which is
right there the rich don't work for
money and then I'm I'm now all confused
as a nine-year-old kid
and so that's when the whole thing
started about financial education for me
I was I was coming out of the Marine
Corps in 74.
and I said to my Rich Dad I wanted to be
an entrepreneur and because my poor dad
wanted me to get my PhD of course fly
for the airlines to get a PhD I'm going
oh my God you know my old man was broke
Poor Dad was broke because he ran full
lieutenant governor of the state of
Hawaii and the dirtiest business there
is this politics
and the governor said to my Dad Poor Dad
he says you'll never work in the state
again
and my poor dad went poor I mean up
until that time he was okay
but once he could not work and he
couldn't sell
and so I come out of the Marine Corps
and he's telling me oh go fly for the
airlines the United Airlines is hiring
and go back to school and get your PhD
like me and I said ask me am I saying
his PhD ascents were poor helpless and
desperate
Jesus I mean he couldn't sell
so I go to a rich dad and I go what
should I do I'm being entrepreneur he
says God sell I'm going oh my God
oh my God that's the worst thing
possible this is 1974.
and because my Old Man Poor Dad kept
saying he says salesman of the scum you
know
and so I said Rich Dad why do I have to
sell he says how's your sex life I said
terrible voices because you can't sell
you know
so I got a job with Xerox
in Honolulu and I went to see
I had to go home to my poor dad and
apologize
so I'm a disappointment to you because I
got a job as a Salesman
and that's when it started you know it
was horrible you know
knocking on doors knocking on doors and
if you don't sell you don't eat also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there is the Fed doing what it can in
your view or is there a different way to
combat uh inflation
well I always say it's not what the
fed's going to do is what are you going
to do and so I always talk about the
Four G's that I'm I'm investing in for
most of my life the first G is gold you
know this is gold and then this is
silver here and I stay away from the
slvs or the glds I want no counterparty
at risk I want the real stuff the other
thing I'm investing is ground I own
apartment houses I'm glad I'm not in
Office Buildings or commercial real
estate
and then gasoline you know gasoline you
know the green the Greenies hate the
thing
but that's how we fly our planes and
stuff like this and then the last one is
food I invest in cattle and uh food so I
just stay in things that as inflation
goes up
gold goes up uh real estate goes up
gasoline goes up and food goes up so I
invest with the inflation not against it
I meet so many people say well I can't
afford this I can't afford that I can't
afford to buy real estate I can't afford
to buy Bitcoin I can't afford to buy
well there is you can't afford to buy
something is because you can't sell
and sales equals income
so back in 1974
you know my my dad wanted me to go to
the University of Hawaii and get my PhD
and I said no I'm gonna well he wanted
to fly for the airlines because of the
pilot
and I said no I'm not going to do that
I'm going to learn how to sell
and it was he was my he was upset
he says you know salesman's a sales
amount of Crux they're con artists you
know it's not it's not a very honorable
profession but that's why he was poor
you know so many PhD types academic
types
they think they're above the capitalist
process process
they think their PHD entitles them
to the better life
but if you go for your PhD you really
don't have the skill sets
to be in the capitalist world
you know like when my my father you know
bless his heart he ran for lieutenant
governor against his boss the governor
as a republican in the People's Republic
of Hawaii you know Hawaii's 100
communist
and uh so he ran as a Republican
and he lost
and the governor said to him you'll
never work in this state again
so the power the governor had over my
dad it was his job
and the hardest thing for a school
teacher Patrick
is you as a capitalist you really don't
need a school teacher you need a
Salesman
and my father just couldn't sell he
wouldn't you know he just kept holding
up his PhD I have a PhD
but he couldn't sell wow and you know
what I mean and and I saw that
and that's when my uh Rich Dad who had
had no education at all said um you
better learn how to sell pretty quickly
so John and I like I said rugby players
believe for the Hawaii Harley Quinn's
Rugby team
and I'm talking to him and he's telling
me about all the rich people we knew in
Hawaii who were going broke I'm going
you got to tell that story
because as I said I you know in 1974 was
the first uh 401K it was called erisa
Employee Retirement income Security Act
and I was still in the Marine Corps and
I was flying out of Hawaii
and I went to listen to these pitches on
how to sell a 401k and I said these guys
are lying through their teeth
because the advantage I had is I had a
rich dad and I had a poor debt and my
poor dad was the village he was a PhD
which tends for poor helpless and
desperate
he ran the school system for the state
of Hawaii and he thought the 401K was
wonderful
I'm going you got to be kidding me
and my rich dad was my best friend's
father he goes oh my God the boy talk
about a license to steal money from
stupid people called employees
so I came from a different so this is 74
I'm still in the Marine Corps
and the first thing my rich dad said to
me if you're going to be a rich man
you'd better learn two things right now
be an entrepreneur you know but he says
you've got to learn how to sell
and secondly you've got to know real
estate because real estate is debt and
taxes and that's what do you mean debt
in taxes
so in 1974 I took my first real estate
course and
opened my eyes up because you don't need
money to buy real estate and you pay no
taxes on top of it
so just before I get out of the Marine
Corps you know I get a job with Xerox
learn how to sell so I got sales
and then I understood real estate so why
am I rich man today because I took two
courses learned how to sell
and learn about real estate and my poor
dad the PHD says go back to school get
your MB and get your PhD I'm going then
I'd wind up like you a poor Highly
Educated man with a 401k humans learn by
making mistakes
you know God designed us is when a baby
learns to walk baby crawls stands up and
Falls stands up and Falls then fine
takes the first step and the next thing
of writing and then flying but what our
schools do when a child Falls to punish
them you're stupid
you make mistakes smart people don't
make mistakes
and when the way when I look at the way
humans were designed to learn we're
designed to learn from mistakes
so that's why you can't you know you
play golf
I'm sure Tiger Woods has had more bad
shots than me he's failed more than me
so when you look at the real reality of
the world the biggest failures are the
most successful
you know like what's his name uh Steve
Jobs never went to you dropped that off
on a Reed College
Gates dropped out of Harvard Michael
Dell at the University of Texas but they
failed their way to success but our
academics say
that's greedy they're capitalists don't
make mistakes and do as I tell you do as
I tell you
and don't question anything I say that's
called tyranny and I really want to talk
to you about the most important subject
for all of us today Rich Young poor old
it's called Financial education
and as you know our school systems teach
us nothing about money nothing it's
pathetic you know they have financial
literacy courses today well that's not
Financial education you know it's really
pathetic and what's happening for most
people today is you know they follow
that age-old Mantra go to school what do
you learn about money in school nothing
get a job well jobs are disappearing not
only that is that with artificial
intelligence and G5 coming more jobs are
going to be wiped out plus with
driverless cars more jobs are getting
wiped out so why would you go to school
to get a job
and then work hard for money but pay and
pay taxes taxes are going to keep going
up sports fans they have to somebody's
going to pay off this massive mountain
of debt stacking up all over the world
and the only way they pay off debt is
via taxes
and then they tell you to get out of
debt of God
debt is money please understand me in
1971 when Nixon took the dollar off the
gold standard money became debt
so the rich know how to use debt
to get rich there are many many people
who always sell you live below your
means well that's not a rich dad
philosophy either I think if you live
below your means and if you're
especially if you're poor already you
live below the means your spirit dies so
what the Rich Dad company is really
about is how do you improve your spirit
by increasing your financial
intelligence or your financial IQ
instead of living below my means or what
most people have as a job a job it can
only work so hard so my goal my wife's
goal every single year is we increase
our assets so we buy more rental
property we invest in oil gold stocks
that pay dividends and all this so every
year our income or our cash flow
keeps increasing every year our goal is
not to get a higher paying job our our
goal is to keep increasing our assets we
want you to have all the wonderful
things this world have still offer so
that's one of the difference between
don't live below your means I we used to
say what we say at Rich does increase
your means and you can have anything you
like and that's what makes the Rich Dad
companies philosophy a little different
than the rest the big mistake that
people make is they they say this these
words here
[Music]
sales and marketing
it's inaccurate against the power of the
word
okay
the real thing that I was trained as the
way it really goes is first it goes
PR
it's really a philosophy above it
[Music]
so PR is public relations
PR is when I'm in the like I'll be in
Newsweek next week Time Magazine next
week I fly to New York on Tuesday to do
a television show with us web broadcast
with Steve Forbes
coming out with a book with Donald Trump
and things like that it's all PR stuff
marketing is kind of the spreadsheet
between it you know marketing plans
testing and all that it's like an
accounting spreadsheet and then there's
a sale
so when times get really really tough
what's the first thing that most
businesses cut back on
[Music]
PRS and marketing so they have no sales
it's really stupid
so what we're doing in our company is
we're upping it 10 times
okay
so Mike so I I went and I spent four
years learning how to sell the reason I
recommend network marketing is if you
can't sell you can't do the rest of the
stuff
it's all right
that's where I recommend it
okay you've got to know how to
communicate today people who are poor
cannot communicate
okay so I spent four years here and I
found that I sucked at it really
terrible
but I went from the war salesman to
number one just by sheer determination
overcoming my fear my embarrassment and
I get my feedback my stats
pretty soon I was making more in a month
than most people were making in a year
that was the thing
and the biggest thing I learned about
sales was the reason most people aren't
successful is they haven't failed enough
times
so for me to become successful at sales
when I worked for Xerox I was making
about four sales calls a day I get a
dial for an appointment and
I'd go in they'd say no I want to go eat
lunch and I go back here they'd say no I
eat lunch I go in and say no eat lunch I
gained 40 pounds
and I talked to my Rich Dad I said why
am I failing at sales he says he says
because you're not failing enough
he says if you want to be successful in
life you have to step up your failure
rate
so
at night I would leave the Xerox office
about six and I'd go across town to a
non-profit and I dial for dollars and I
wanted to get 30 no's a night
as fast as I could and the more I failed
the more my sales went up
does that make sense you guys here
hello
I went wow
so the reason most people are not
successful is because they haven't
failed enough
so please discuss that really quick it
doesn't make a difference what it is
could be golf tennis sales marketing
anything language of money is a very
good you know the definition of the word
so and the good thing about it is you
want to be a rich just learn the like to
speak the language of money like if I
wanted to go to let's say Spain I would
learn Spanish I'm a fourth generation
Japanese I want to go to Japan I learn
Japanese
but when you go to a school system you
learn the language of a school teacher
go to school get a job work hard save
money pay taxes get our debt and buy a
house because it's an asset
but all you have to do is learn the
words so my poor dad called his house an
asset and my Rich Dad said your house is
a liability again it's just the Power of
Words and language so the difference
between rich people and poor people are
words and words are free
and when I said oh and it naturally it
upsets the school teachers who are
mostly I'm not they're not bad people
when I was in 1965 I read the Communist
Meadow Festival by Marx
and as I read I went to military school
in New York and reading the book I
realized my God
my family is communist wow so they
believed in taxes
they believed in you know the abolished
real estate you know today Claude Schwab
says you will have nothing and you'll be
happy
that's all Communist Manifesto stuff
this past week it seems like the big
banks are going to get bigger despite
everything the administration really
hopes happens here you know
can you just talk about whether these
Trends you when you say it comes back to
us and what we're doing but are some of
the things that you or that the others
are doing making it worse for the guy
who's just trying to to get ahead
well I'm a big advocate for financial
education so in the 1970s when I got out
of the Marine Corps my rich dad had me
take two things I had to learn how to
sell because sales equals income and
then I had to learn how to invest in
real estate because real estate is debt
so most people say you know live debt
free I had to learn to use debt as money
and as you guys know in 7 Day One Nixon
took the dollar off the gold standard
and the US dollar became debt so I do
almost everything opposite of what the
pundits say I I'm not debt free I use
debt as money to acquire real estate and
that minimizes my taxes that's what I do
that was one of the biggest wake-up
calls in my life is that there isn't
between rich people and poor people is
they don't know real money from fake
money my mom and dad didn't good people
but they don't know that so they spent
it
and so today you know I have millions
and millions and millions in gold and
silver and I also use debt I don't use
money and guys like Dave Ramsey said
will say live debt free and for 99 of
the people that's good advice but if
you're going to be really rich you have
to learn how to use debt as money but to
do that you gotta be a lot smarter and
some hodler you know chasing ethereum
and all the other stuff okay so that's
what real Financial education I don't
have an answer I know it's going to
happen in the future could my Bitcoin go
to zero yes but gold and silver have
been here since the earth was formed
it's been goal it's been the money for
about 12 000 years Bitcoin has been
money for 10. now does that mean I don't
buy Bitcoin no I still will buy it but
I'll buy it because it's liquid I can
get out of it if I made a mistake most
people go to school to become employees
it stands for E employee
or they become Specialists like social
media guys
but where rich dad is different is that
this is what you go to school for become
doctors or lawyers or accountants or
pizza shop owners but this is the B and
the I side this is big business and this
is in professional investor not stocks
not mutual funds not ETFs not 401ks not
that stuff professional investor so the
problem with most Millennials they went
to school they came out here right
that's correct yeah that's the problem
what Rich Dad does was shift you to
think on this side so the B and the I
side 500 employees or more a
professional investor you want 401ks and
stuff that's on this site
but you have the power with this thing
to go over here
so my whole message is this and this is
often my Rich Dad
this is called the bi triangle B and I
to be a big business owner and investor
there's eight steps to it number one yes
of a mission statement for your company
number two got to have a team number
three you have to have leadership
and now then you have product
everybody's all got a great product well
product is the least important thing
then you have to have legal you know you
have to patent all the contracts systems
you know a card automobile is a system
of systems a computer is a system of
systems the human body is a system of
systems that's why they have a good team
you have to communication this is the
most powerful communication device
ever
you know but most people use it to text
and
complain and check their social media
accounts I mean grow up you guys and
then here we have cash flow you know
cash received they're flowing in or
flowing out
and this is leadership so Shane is over
here on the leadership side he
coordinates all these people with this
thing is that correct absolutely yep so
you have the most powerful tool in
history so let me say this before I
begin because we're talking about going
to school or education whatever that is
to you and education is more important
than ever before but the problem I have
with school traditional education
number one today is is creating young
people are here to be greatly in debt
right with pension let me have pension
but some student loans subprime student
loans I got a subprime education so
education is more important before but
what do they teach you about money
nothing nothing so my point here is this
education is important
but the thing I don't like about
labeling a child or a student add okay
ADT is another word for extreme boredom
why don't they just call it what it is a
child doesn't have add the teacher is
boring they're boring boring boring
people why would I listen to them so I
had ATT but I call it acute boredom
then they say you have dyslexia well
what the heck is that I have dyslexia
because I was sound asleep I was always
drooling you know I couldn't believe how
boring the teacher was on top of that
they were teaching me a subject I wasn't
interested in you know when I had
calculus and trigonometry I kept going
what am I going to use this stuff you
know
so anyway this is my point of view
education is the only business that
blames the customer for the teachers in
keep
incompetence let me say it again
education is the only business where
you're allowed to blame the customer for
the teacher's incompetence you see in
business I can't do that you know if my
students are failing or my customers are
failing
that I'm responsible for it but who how
the world can these teachers get away
with blaming their customers
for the teachers and education systems
in competence and let me say this one
more time education is more important
before
but what the heck are you learning that
you're stupid I was called stupid so
many times I almost went nuts I flunked
out of high school twice when I was 15
and 17 because I can't write
and today I've sold more books than most
teachers ever will it's in the millions
of books
so who was stupid you know that's the
whole point here is this become a
professional invest it's not easy you
gotta study a lot
but this is what I see coming
okay financial statement it's the
balance sheet
what I'm concerned about for the
Millennials okay so here we have
M for Millennials it's a lot of you
but over here we have
today
boom baby boomer is me
and what's going to happen is that
it's going to be the flow of people
these guys are you guys going to flow
over here
and you'll be producing the income to
pay the taxes and all this
these guys are going to come over here
we're going to be the biggest
liabilities you've ever seen
they estimate that and nobody knows the
real number
but the estimations are this bill for
all the social programs the welfare
programs all the social security
retirement plans and all this is SMA to
be 265 trillion dollars
you guys gonna have to pay for that
so when all guys like me move over here
and you guys take over the economy here
uh what's going to happen is
go up
you have to pay taxes to pay for these
guys
so that's that's why when I speak to
young people and all this I I kind of
joke around a lot things like this
but this is a massive massive massive
massive social problem
you know like if your mother and father
had no money what would you have to do
you have to pay for them right
can you afford their health care right
now I don't think so you know like I cut
my finger here two years ago the bill
was thirty four thousand dollars a one
stitch
thirty four thousand dollars
that's where this comes that's their
estimate they don't know how much this
is going to be total all the national
debt and all this and as we're talking
you know they can't balance
they need to extend the budget to pay
for our bills and all this and it's only
going to get worse
so when I speak to your generation Our
Generation headed really easy we're
going to cruise over here
you guys have had it pretty hard and
it's going to get worse it's my opinion
so that's why the idea of go to school
get a job work hard save money get out
of debt put in a 401k
that was my generation it didn't work
for us but you guys are going to try the
same thing if you want to be an
entrepreneur you've got to study with
Chris Voss
I mean the number one skill of an
entrepreneur is communication
you can call it negotiation you call it
sales you can call whatever you want
but as my friend Blair singer says to me
all the time it says sales equals income
do you know and if you want to find
somebody who can't sell
if their income is low or vice versa
but more than that I've been
we interviewed Chris years ago and his
first book came out never split the
difference
and uh I hate to say I didn't read the
book but I will read the book now I'll
admit that
and all I remembered from that was a lot
of people I remember from Chris was the
the midnight DJ you know voice and all
that so I was practicing that
but what really worked for us I'm going
to surprise Kim on this because you know
about three or four years ago Kim says
I'm out of here I don't want to be
married to you anymore I want que pasa
what did I do wrong you know what did I
do wrong then I was listening to you
discuss my friend Donald the Trump and
he's a really good friend of ours but
what you said about him it just hit me
right between the eyes I was going
holy mackerel Donald plays win lose
you know he has to win he wins at all
cost
and I was going oh my God and then what
even this is not your words but I
paraphrase this thing but if you play
Win Lose
pretty soon people stop playing
and then that's exactly it yeah and
that's my way of saying with Kim you
know we're talking before the show came
on I went to military school I mean day
one we're screamed at there's no
compassion then I joined the Marine
Corps and I learned to adapt to that
behavior
do you know that you talk to everybody
like a Moraine so for 35 years I talked
to Kim like a Moraine and one day she
said I've had enough
so when you when when I read when I was
listening one of your podcasts I went oh
my God
so I want to thank you because what your
technology is more than sales it's more
than negotiations you have the key to
World Peace if we could learn to speak
with kindness and Humanity
and support one of the biggest mistakes
I still hear it today
from young people oh
I don't have to worry because I'm still
young yeah and that is death to most
people because eventually they get old
and then you're not young again so it's
a way of saying when I talk about assets
and liabilities
one of the most important things you
have in your life is time it's one of
your greatest assets or it's your
liability
and being and I just turned 70 and I
have friends who have nothing
I mean they have zero now they may
they've made a lot of money
but they have nothing here they have
nice houses nice cars
16 lives 19 kids I don't know what they
have but you know what I mean
and and being young is great except it
can be a liability to you
because when you're young you're just
having a lot of fun and life's exciting
you know it's new
so at the time but the thing is this is
the lesson today
is so many people spend their time
focusing
here
they want to make a lot of money
and I can hear it in their words they
say oh
I want a career
this is career okay or I'm going to
start my own business and
this is the chart here which we've seen
this is the cash flow Quadrant Book
number two he is employee s is small
business self-employed or a specialist
like a doctor lawyer web web designer be
as big business 500 employees or more
and I is professional investor so when I
was your age I knew I wanted to get here
this takes time this is the hardest you
know
this is where the big Megabucks are and
Kim and I are here and the money is
massive but it takes time to get there
the big mistake I see young people make
as they focus here
and the words are I want to do what I
love
that's the track
you see in the real life sometimes you
have to do what you hate
like people think I like to write books
I hate writing books
but it fills my purpose in life it's not
my passion my purpose in life
because my purpose was to get here a lot
of these guys get trapped here doing
what they love
as we've talked about on earlier
episodes of this scene you guys pay the
highest taxes 40 percent here
60 in taxes here
twenty percent here and then zero
percent here
so when I was in my before my 20s
I knew I wanted to go there and it
wasn't doing what I loved I had to learn
what I didn't want to learn
I sometimes have to do what I hate it I
had to learn about taxes I had to learn
about debt I had to take classes I had
to learn about insurance
so I was doing a lot of things I hated
doing so I could come over here these
guys never do this because they live
their passion I want my passion
the different passion is greedy purpose
is for other people so my purpose was to
come over here so I could serve more
people
so I have employees here and all this I
don't buy stocks bonds mutual funds
because as a professional investor I can
create my own assets there's three kinds
of money today that you guys got to be
aware of one is God's money and God's
money is gold and silver so this is
silver and this is gold the reason I
brought it most people don't know what
it looks like and then there's
government money which is fiat currency
which is the dollar the Yen the peso the
Euro the Yuan yeah
fake and everybody's working hard for it
it's like eating fake food or drinking
fake water that's why people are getting
sick financially because they're working
for fake money yeah okay and then
there's fake assets was another part of
the fake Millennial the fake generation
series
but the reason I brought this here is
most people haven't seen it this here is
real silver Plata okay
that's what it looks like and so in 1972
And this here is gold yeah
this is God 's money this is what God's
money looks like the reason I call it
God's money is you can't fake it
you know you can fake it with a fake ETF
like a gold ETF or a silver which I
don't touch because it smells as bad as
the guys that printed that crap
you know what I mean Jesus
but this is real money so
you look at this here
when I first started buying that that
was a dollar forty yeah today that's 16
dollars
and this here is auto gold
and the reason we brought it is most
people haven't seen or touched this is
real this is God's money why did I say
it's God's money because he was here
when the Earth was created and it'll be
here when we're all dead and gone when
you're saving those fake dollars this
will still be here yeah or those fake
ETFs or those fake stocks what if you're
a generation are saying tax to Rich
as they say never happened Joe because
the tax laws need the rich
to do what the government wants done
their incentives I provide housing jobs
and food and energy
so that's what they should be teaching
but our schools will never teach that
because they're fake teachers
I think I'll say that's kind of a review
of Rich Dad Poor Dad yeah thank God you
gave that I mean even when you when you
were talking about jobs it's like well
yeah none of us would be here if it
wasn't for you creating this company
yeah and so
um it's kind of curious as to why the
government wouldn't want us to be
creating more houses more more companies
why aren't they making us learn this in
school well because it's fake education
it's been going on for hundreds of years
and like I said what the rich took over
there was rockefeller's Carnegie Mellon
and they said let's you know we don't
need more entrepreneurs we need more
employees
so the purpose of American education is
to create soldiers and employees people
with the stewards are tall but know
nothing about money marketing and sales
are a brilliant thing and it's a it's a
global discipline right no matter if
you're doing business uh no matter where
you're doing business it's a global
discipline you just got to be committed
to it and you can't give up on it but
you have to spend your dollars wisely
and that's uh that's most important and
what what Vic is selling most small
business people cut back
they stop spending when they should be
spending on marketing and advertising
because sales equals income
they get scared so what's let's let's
leave that as tip number one and if
you're not an entrepreneur
just now that bad times are the best
times sometimes to start a business I've
only started in bad times because
everything else is going to shut down
and lots of opportunity when things are
slow what happens is like many small
business people they cut back on the
spending on marketing and advertising
or they they market and advertise to the
wrong customer if you're just starting
out and you're right here you may not
have much money may not have a job and
all this but that's really not an excuse
because you can still start and I would
suggest you know getting Kenny's ABCs of
real estate looking at programs because
uh we're gonna go into let's start on
how I started it was
uh the reason I got into real estate was
that my Rich Dad this is back in the 70s
he knew that President Nixon had taken
the dollar off of the gold standard and
the prices were starting to rise and so
rich dad said one thing he says don't
save money learn how to use debt and so
it's counter-intuitive to what most
people think because most financially
advisors they save money and get out of
debt we're saying don't save money get
into debt so it's a different process
you know so that's really it the reason
I invest with Kenny is because we're
into debt debt
you see the beauty of real estate over
stocks there is there's margins of
things that with stocks but with real
estate banks are really anxious to lend
you money if you're good if you're not
good they don't lend you money so again
it goes back to when somebody says I
don't have money it's because you don't
have Financial you don't have education
you know stuff like this and this and
this you go I don't have money so I
don't start well you're not supposed to
use your own money anyway and that's
what that was paying Rich dad's lesson
to me back in the 70s it says look the
dollar is no longer backed by gold the
dollar is now backed by debt U.S
treasuries and it says if you're going
to be rich you'd better understand how
to use debt I mean well the other people
the other Financial people oh save save
and put your money on the mutual funds
the postmodern is Communists the Marxist
in our academic system they speak in
these platitudes like equality this that
you know and it's just it's as
non-specific as possible but as a
capitalist I must speak in facts figures
and the history but they want to change
history you know the 1619 project or
whatever that is
and the real fact is you know America
and then we're going to pay taxes well
Mark said uh graduate income tax is
essential for the spread of Communism
and so my father Poor Dad he believed in
paying taxes my Rich Dad didn't again
the word is taxes
and so when you look at what Biden's
doing right now he just he just put in
87 000 IRS agents who are armed
the reason is they're going after you
small business they're going after the
small entrepreneur they can't touch me
you know because I'm not that stupid to
pay taxes and I can do it legally
but that's why I give make fun of my
friends Peter Schiff and Mark Moss you
know they're living in Puerto Rico I
said if you're a real estate guy you
wouldn't live in Puerto Rico you could
live anywhere you want not pay taxes you
know I invest with Kenny McElroy in real
estate so let's say buys a building for
a million to keep the numbers simple
he increases the rent so that he
refinances the building at 2 million
so we have a million in debt he borrows
out another million but now 2 million in
debt
and I get the he and I get the million
dollars extra how much in tax do we pay
for that extra million zero zero and who
pays the debt
the tenants the tenants
Rich dad's World teaches capitalism so
I'll read you something because this
comes from this book here the capitalist
Manifesto because years ago 1965 I read
this book here the Communist man of
Festival by Marx
and Marx was just like my poor dad an
academic and the trouble with academics
is our poor they have no idea how
capitalism works
so stay tuned in the end of this program
to find out how capitalism works
so once you understood this I understood
my Rich Dad why he did things the way he
did and my poor dad hated my Rich Dad my
rich dad's my best friend's father
Rich Dad had all these houses and he
paid no taxes and he owned hotels he was
playing Monopoly and Rich Dad paid no
taxes
and my poor dad being a communist but
didn't know it
he hated the rich
and that's what marks did Marx hated the
rich
but I want to read you a quote from Marx
so all of you who believe that paying
taxes is patriotic this comes from this
book here the capitalist Manifesto and
this book here the Communist metal
festive it says here
a heavy
or Progressive
or graduated
income tax is necessary
for the proper development of communism
let me read it again to you this is
Marshall's words if you want to verify
just read this book here okay it says a
heavy or Progressive
or graduated income tax is necessary
for the proper development of communism
and that's what's happening in America
so if you want to be a communist you
stay on this side here
you want to be a capitalist you come to
this side here and again Rich dad's
World offers you opportunities to
understand this side not this side here
but anyway that's why I've that's why
Tom is one of my go-to guys
because the less tax I pay the more
capitalistic I become that's right Freer
I become what are things that you're
thinking about because with every
downside there's an upside someone's get
it's like the way I think about it it's
a zero-sum economy money never leaves
the ecosystem it just moves and changes
hands so where's the power going where's
the money going this here is a 1964
silver dollar it's real silver what
happened in 1964
I think it was Johnson one of those guys
he he took the silver out of this coin
so this silver dollar today is worth ten
dollars
and I tell the story of going into
Safeway at the salad bar
and these women are asking the same
question what should I invest in
and I said well give me ten dollars for
this
they go it's a half dollar why would I
give you ten dollars for this I said
because this could be the best
investment of all I've been collecting
silver since I was 17 years old
I own Silver Mines and I own gold mines
so when the dollar goes down gold and
silver go up this here is book number
two in the Rich Dad series it's called
the cash flow quadrant
so e stands for employees so you go to
school until you go to school get a job
but if you're really smart like Tom
you become s stands for super smart
you become accountants attorneys and
doctors so Tom who pays the most taxes
of these characters here oh that
definitely the S definitely the super
smart the the the more degrees you have
the more tax you pay
I I said Thank God most of your friends
Tom are like me see students
we didn't qualify for this one here uh
that's for sure
you educate all of us
well
that as a general rule and this is
worldwide too this is not just us right
that's the time and I have traveled the
world and employees pay about
40 percent in taxes trying to say about
that and that's worldwide that that is
that's a that's a pretty standard rate
worldwide it's going to be anywhere from
30 to 50 but on average 40 if you make
any kind of decent wage you're going to
be up in that 40 range correct and if
you're a doctoral lawyer self-employed
or like somebody says I'm going to quit
my job and start my own business you
become a small business owner or a
specialist I'm going to be a web
designer
how much of these guys pay in taxes here
well they they can get all the way up to
60 percent in tax because they're paying
not just the employee share they're
paying the employer's share as well so
they pay two taxes employer and employee
so that's what happens when people quit
their job and start their own business
without talking to Tom first
okay so big b stands for big business
which is according to the tax code 500
employees
but Bay also stands for brand right and
most people don't build a brand here
so big business like the big
corporations how much do they pay uh
typically around twenty percent twenty
percent
and again what time instructs people and
advises people
it's because we're doing what the
government wants done
so why would the government give a tax
break to Big Business well because
that's where the jobs are right so one
of the government's primary goals is to
create jobs and employment and so the
big business doesn't pay the taxes in
the B quadrant it's the E people who
work for the big business who pay the
taxes right the government needs people
to hire these people here correct and so
if you hire a lot of people they'll give
you a tax break for that
and then I stands for investor but it's
an inside investor
now there's over here a lot of people
invest but they invest in a 401k or an
IRA invest in public market
like stocks bonds mutual funds ETS which
I don't I don't have any of those things
I don't want them
but over here as an Insider
or investor how much do they pay well
they they they're the ones who get down
to zero
and pay zero tags
so if you enjoy being over here
you can tune out right now interesting
thing is these guys here can do this
they can if they have a good attorney
also right that's right
so that's why I have Garrett Sutton and
his he's our attorney but you have to
act like these people you can't act like
these people what do you want young
people young civilians today to
understand maybe a lesson or uh or or or
um
or an experience you've had serving our
country from the Marine Corps that you
wish young people could learn today
I studied this book Communist Manifesto
I read the ninth I went to the academy
merch Marine Academy you know and it's
also I pointed to a Naval Academy but I
took my train Academy but the most
important thing is this when I was
flying this aircraft we went down three
times crashed
wouldn't get a shot down the aircraft
was so tired you know you just kept
falling out of the sky but the thing
that works we had the best team
you know as soon as my engine quit I was
about 1500 feet flying into North
Vietnam not North but just south of the
military zone my engine quit
immediately
what pilots do is they raise the nose
generally
what to train us to do
is dive the nose
and so moment I did that I I heard my
crew members they were jealousing all
the cans of ammunition dropping the
machine guns and dropping the rocket
pods and where we were in the water
within like 10 seconds
but it was the most powerful team young
guys too two pilots one Crew Chief and
two young Marine Gunners we're a team so
what's going to get you through
probably the next 10 years is how tight
your friends are how tight your team is
you know so that's why I count you as
one of my assets
because you you allow me to speak and as
you know our freedom of speech is being
taken away
as this guy demanded
so it's going to depend upon who your
friends are you know are they smart they
stupid
and things like this so when things
happen
you know you gotta have a team my team
at Rich Dad is ungodly they are such a
high performance team small with only 10
people but we kick ass wherever we go
and thanks a lot to my wife my wife did
a great job you know I wouldn't be here
without Kim
and we're a Titan Kim and I get divorced
unfortunately but your team right now is
crucial so the final word says Maureen
say to each other Semper Fi
Semper Fi means forever faithful the
older I get I go the more I don't know
and uh crypto is taking over the world
and uh I was just on my phone to my gold
and silver dealer and I still own gold
and silver and I bought a lot of crypto
but it's a very important subject that
if we need to be aware of
and once again the Rich Dad we don't
recommend anything but we just do our
best to give you the information so you
can make your own decisions and I still
own uh some quite a bit of Bitcoin and
ethereum
but I'm waiting for the price to come
down
before I buy more take another position
in both Bitcoin and
um ethereum
I just want people to know that to know
and think because I get promoted all the
often time you got to get down on this
one oh you got to get her on that one
that's what's going to go to the Moon
you know I'm an old man I've heard this
so many so many times over all
these years in real estate stocks
you know and and that's why we have the
Rich Dad Radio Show it's not to promote
anything but the idea of understanding
what's good and what's bad about
something how do we generate cash flow
passive income which is one of the
tenants you preached enriched that poor
dad in today's high inflationary
environment well I'm still a real estate
guy but I'm not I've never been I've
never been a flipper you know guys were
buying a house for ten thousand it's
only for 20 I don't do that stuff
I buy income producing real estate like
if you owned farmland and it's producing
let's say
Alfalfa that's an asset
I own cattle I own I own a wagyu cattle
because
what I sell is the wagyu Bulls semen you
know those cash flow I should change
that to semen flow
and what that's hanging behind me is you
know George Gammon he always talks about
the economy is hanging on this hot air
balloon and that little basket down
there is us you know just dangling from
this balloon
and that balloon happened in um as most
people know in 2008
when Bernanke who was awarded the Nobel
Prize can you imagine that
printed trillions of dollars to blow the
economy into a bubble and it was the
everything bubble you know stocks and
bonds went up real estate went up and he
kept dropping interest rates so the so
the dollar became more valuable
but what what happened this year David
is that balloon's coming down
it's called what Andy Chapman calls the
three times crash stock spawns and
mutual funds crash
real estate crashes and cash is trash
that's going to start flying the US
dollar I mean it's going to start
flowing back to the U.S because
treasuries are going down if you don't
have gold and I mean physical goal or
physical silver
you better start doing it now because of
the US dollar although JS Canadian he
can see sometimes clearer than Americans
can't house screwed up our dollar is
yesterday I panicked
goal push 2000 U.S I don't know what it
isn't Canadian in the Looney but um
I think next stop is five thousand for
gold
okay it may take another five years but
I think it
um you know this this here is a real
gold coin
and my first the first one I ever bought
was in 1972 I bought it in Hong Kong
and I paid fifty dollars for this and
today it's two thousand dollars plus
plus plus plus and this also has a
silver coin this is real silver
I don't like fake money
and that's why this Vancouver resource
investment conference was important
because you come to hear about why if
you don't have gold I mean physical gold
and silver you should have some now and
today we have both good news and bad
news and the bad news is the world
economy is collapsing
but the good news is the number one
investment that everybody in the world
can afford
is silver
everybody and that's the good news but
will most people buy it now they'll save
money instead and they'll save money in
spite of the fact that they're printing
trillions of it gresham's law is in full
force right now bad money is pumping
into this system and all these idiots
you know it's called Financial stupidity
they're saving dollars you got to be
kidding me and they're printing they're
printing so much money and the beauty of
silver let me say it again everybody in
the world can afford 20 bucks or you can
afford a dime you know I mean you can go
to a coin store yeah I'd like a night on
a 1963 dime you might pay a buck for it
but that's how stupid people are and
they don't realize that
silver has not only been an industrial
metal but it's also a monetary medal
it's been used as you know payments for
years and years and years so I got this
job at Xerox the same story you have I
got my little handy dandy sales planner
up I'm dying
you know let's say there's 20 sales guys
at the Xerox branch in Honolulu I'm
dying I mean I'm like and the this guy
Sanchez flies in from western region
Santa Ana he looks at my my uh sales
thing and I got all these appointments
but no sales
you know and I'm gonna get fired
so I I can't I'm working hard
but I'm gonna get fired
you know because I had no sales
so I go my rich dad's office was a
Waikiki so I got a rich dad's office and
I show up my planner he looks at it he
goes
okay he says let me ask you this
how many and you know you get back to
knock on doors I had no established
accounts the fngs and the fnu guy has to
always cold call
you know that's as brutal as it comes
so I'm cold calling call calling call
calling on Honolulu I'm getting nowhere
but I'm making a lot of cold calls
so I show my Rich Dad my sales planner
just like you you deal with your guys
and I said my rich chances well it's
obviously why you're failing
I said why is that he says
you're not failing enough
he says if you want to get become
successful
you have to step up your failure rate
I want what
because in my poor dad's family the
academics family phds and all this
failure means you're not successful
and to my Rich Dad failure Matt you were
getting successful
so his advice to me and I still working
for Xerox I'm probably 28 years old
he goes you gotta step up your failure
rate find a way to fail faster
so that's when you get creative you know
I can only make so many sales calls a
day what is the biggest difference
between fear today versus fear 50 years
ago versus fear 100 years ago versus
fear 20 years ago isn't this a common
thing like when Market does well economy
does well a few people are prepared for
it most people kind of sit around don't
do anything about it what's changed and
is that going to be happening 50 years
from now 100 years from now where people
who capitalize and most don't
well that's a fabulous question because
you know today when I refer to 2008 most
people remember 2008.
did I mean that's when women went down
of course 38 drop yeah they they all
remember it but I want to say what you
did was really really smart because the
best time to start a business is right
after a crash I made more money after
2008 than every my whole entire life
because everybody was hiding like little
cockroaches wow you made more money
after 2008 in your entire life yeah so
when you know here I'm talking about the
coming depression everybody says oh
you're you're such a pessimist you know
like I know I'm excited you know I got
sexually stimulated thinking about it
all the bargains that are going to be on
the street you know I mean
I mean it's gonna be Bargains everywhere
but everybody else oh you're pessimistic
no I'm actually optimist
so anyway so you're very smart just you
know what I study I study business guys
who start right after our crash do very
well most of the time if you have money
you have more power
if you have attractiveness and sex
appeal and all that you have more power
so I think one of the most misunderstood
words here is power
and that's why we have Rallo on this
program it's about power so and whether
you and I don't know if you want it or
you don't want it but I would say most
people want more money
people want to be more attractive to be
more you know sexually attractive or
have great relationships and things like
this
but also you want more power the ability
to do because many people today are
trapped you know when people lack power
their lives are kind of different
so power is simply the ability to do and
one of the biggest abilities is can you
change an addiction
into a good habit can you take a bad
habit into a good habit
so for example ever since meeting Rallo
in the gang I was able to break my habit
of overeating I overeat every time I'm
under stress you know what do I need to
do I need to eat
and thanks to Dr Nicole shred Nicky and
Ultra healthy human I and you know the
encouragement are rich and Rallo have
been able to get my body back down to
Marine Corps weight and I'm 74. so I
have the body of a 25 year old now when
I was in the Marine Corps
but I had to get over the addiction of
eating that was tough
you know thank God I didn't drink that
much or smoke
but though that's power so did you ever
wonder how the rich don't pay taxes of
course I mean it went viral when Trump
said he's paid zero in taxes and so it
got me wondering too it's like well one
how can I do that right because I need
that I mean it would be great if I could
pay zero in taxes and two how exactly
can they structure it to get zero in
taxes it goes over here to um
fake money fake teachers fake assets
it's all the same and all of these guys
who are screaming for the rich not to
pay taxes I cover it in fake I actually
have an article from The New York Times
where they interviewed Jared Kushner who
was Trump's son-in-law you know was
ivanka's husband yeah they're they're
they're richer than the trumps Jared
kushner's family the richer than the
trumps but the reason Jared explains it
why these guys pay no tax is because
they're in real estate
they're not in stock spots mutual funds
and ETFs
and so he explains it so the reason the
rich don't pay taxes is because there's
three types of income they'll never
teach you this in school the fake
teachers and everything number one type
of there's three types of income
okay number one type of income is earned
income
that's earned income
it's when you work for money it's earned
so that earned income
shows up here
so these are the guys that pay tax so
when all the guys of screaming taxed are
rich
well you can't tax them because they
don't have jobs
that's absolutely it's kind of funny
isn't it we're going tax to Rich oh yeah
good luck you know and then the second
type of income
okay
his portfolio income and portfolio
income is from flipping houses or you
buy a stock for like ten dollars you
sell it for twenty dollars
that's portfolio income
okay I don't do that Trump doesn't do
that
so most guys are flipping houses and all
that buying stocks and flipping them for
two
you're getting this type of income so
this
this income is about twenty percent
today
some of that here
but the income that the rich work for
is called
passive income
passive income is also known as cash
flow
that's the name of our game
cash flow
and that income his income that's
flowing from here to here
it bypasses taxes
so I know this doesn't sound fair and it
isn't fair I don't disagree with you but
what's not fair is our schools which are
part of the problem will never explain
that and so because it's passive income
is it not taxed because I guess you guys
are creating jobs and owning and
providing houses
you're getting smarter there it's not
illegal because
the tax laws are incentives to do what
the government wants done so the reason
the Trump scale sockets and kushner's
pay no taxes is we provide housing
number two in the B column we provide
jobs so we pay no taxes
and three you know it's a bad word it's
oil when you drill for oil you pay no
taxes
but if you buy Chevron you pay taxes
stocks
if you provide food you pay no taxes
so if real Financial education which
will never be taught in school because
they're fake teachers when I was nine
years old my rich dad taught me how to
become rich by playing the game of
Monopoly and I didn't understand why I
was playing this game of Monopoly and
one day Rich Dad said to me it says
there's many ways you can become rich
one of the best ones I found this game
Monopoly because games are some of the
best teachers in the world because all
games engage for intelligences number
one is your mind
number two are your emotions you know
fear and anger and sadness number three
is physical I mean how can you learn to
walk if you don't fall down and number
four is spiritual intelligence
as Maria Montessori said what the hand
does the Mind remembers as you know we
learn little to nothing in school but in
fact
you'll find out that going to school
actually diminishes your ability to get
rich
you know so that goes counter to what
everybody tells you go to school get a
job and you'll make money
and that worked probably a thousand
years ago not working today you know it
didn't work for me I mean I have a
college degree but I learned nothing
about money
you know and what I've learned I had to
learn on my own from my Rich Dad
so we're going to talking about
School
making mistakes
and we're going to talk to you about
cheating okay my favorite yes subject
okay so in school what do you have to do
to cheat I'd say finding a smart person
in class and looking at their paper
you see when I was in school the
definition definition of cheating was I
asked a smart girl like you
and that's how I got through school
I always sat next to the smartest girl
in my class
and the teachers kept throwing me out
because it said you're cheating
when I go to my Rich Dad he goes That's
not cheating that's cooperation
and so I have my poor dad who would have
said I was cheating and my Rich Dad said
I was cooperating
to the two different points of view now
there's this brand new book out I'm
having everybody in the company I read
it it's called Big potential
and it's by Sean acore now he's not a
flunkier like me he was 12 years at
Harvard as a teacher and all this stuff
there and he studied all these students
and he's the one that found out that the
age of suicide is going down kids are
committing suicide at a younger age
and depression went from age 28 to 14.
and he said the reason is is because how
we teach kids
so all you School teachers out there
don't read this book because you're
going to find out you're damaging kids
but worse than all it's making it harder
to get rich
because what he talks about here in this
is in school they talk to you about the
survival of the fittest
the a student we nased in it no
I was not an a student either I was a c
student
and I found out that by cheating I was
actually preparing myself to do well in
business the big thing about risk here
is this
in school they compensate for a risk by
telling you to memorize the right answer
so in other words these kids leave young
people like you leave school think oh if
I know the right answers then there's no
risk and it drives old guys like me
crazy
because everybody's talking about
Millennials what's wrong with them you
know Millennials are the most highly
immediate the most highly educated
generation in history they have the cell
phone they didn't get educated in school
they got educated on social media on the
cell phones
they know all the answers but they're
afraid of doing anything yeah you know
the biggest complaint about my
generation is Millennials know all the
answers but they can't do anything and
the reason they can't do anything is
because you might hurt they're
somebody's feelings you might make a
mistake you know that's just keeps you
guys just trapped in this little box
here yeah so that's one of the reasons I
think Millennial money is such an
important Point here because if you're
going to come into my world old guy's
world or
the information age you've really got to
understand what is risky and what is not
risky and in my world if you play it
safe
that makes you stupid
because if you don't take risks you
don't get smarter yeah you know so you
may know the answer but you can't do
anything yeah and one of the best things
I had is I went from I went to military
schools I went to Flight School
I have such great teachers you know all
of them could fly you know so my flight
instructor could fly what a novel idea
you know a flight instructor can fly but
when I was in high school
most of my teachers were
terrified they're all cowards you know
job security don't make mistakes just
memorize the right answer and you'll be
safe and that's why most School teachers
aren't Rich yeah and they teach that to
your generation yeah and most of them
are teaching us things that they don't
do on a daily basis like we have
entrepreneurship classes oh and they're
not entrepreneurs you know so it's it's
kind of frightening when you think we're
relying on the school system and the
fact that they're teaching us so the way
to get through college right is
practicing all the right answers taking
the exam putting in all the right
answers when in real life that's the
last thing that'll ever happen right no
like you talk about
fake you know this is my book fake here
fake money fake teachers fake assets the
reason it's fake money fake teachers and
fake assets is because it all has to be
fake you have to have fake teachers to
understand fake money
they have to have fake assets to buy
those stock sponsored mutual funds fake
assets
but without fake teachers fake money you
can't do it
so that's why I love I love working with
on these programs here because if you're
going to be successful you've got to
take some risk yeah and when you make
you take a risk you make a mistake and
you might learn something because we're
supposed to learn from our mistakes look
at Tiger Woods the greatest golfer in
the world one of the greatest athletes
he spent a lot of mistakes
tonight he would not be a great golfer
sitting in a room listening to a teacher
who never played golf tell tiger how to
be a golfer
and somebody but I remember don't take
any risk don't pick up that putter don't
pick up that driver don't hit something
because you might go out of bounds so
don't take any risks and that's why your
generation
is more screwed than my generation yeah
I mean and in class we look up to the
person that knows all the right answers
like so really it's it's just this this
mentality of having to be perfect and to
have this perfect intelligence and know
all the rest I know all the right
answers when that's the person that'll
probably be the least successful in life
because they're not willing to make
these so let me say this again education
is more important than before but you
got to be careful what you're learning
that's why I wrote the book fake money
fake teachers and fake assets don't
listen to fake teachers yeah I have a
friend
he teaches entrepreneurship at UC Santa
Barbara
and I call them up and I say how in the
world can you teach entrepreneurship he
says well I have a master's degree I
said ask the question again
what gives you the right to teach your
entrepreneurship he says
I have a master's degree in
entrepreneurship and I say hey Doug you
and I have been friends for a long time
you've never started a business
you're a fake teacher he goes
but I have all the answers I said yeah
but you don't know how to start a
business
so that's why I do again what I do
education is more important before but
be careful there's fake money fake
teachers and fake assets like some of
the biggest fake dishes of those
financial planners they're telling to
him you know to save money why would you
say whatever the government's printing
money
then they tell you that vessel the long
term in the stock market and you guys
know the stock market is ultra short
term there's high frequency trading
today long term is a Split Second
but they're telling you guys like my
generation to keep your money in the
stock market for 40 years and you have
nothing left at the end of it
then they tell you to save money what
the heck's wrong with this I get a
little Disturbed every time because it
happens like five times a day a young
man or young woman come up to me oh I'm
getting my real estate license oh I'm
buying real estate listen at the top of
a market
so the reason I highly recommend if you
subscribe to only one newsletter there's
lots of them out there
is Bert Doman d-o-h-m-e-n Capital
research his Wellington report and again
he has his free book I mean his free
advisory surviving soaring inflation the
opportunity of a lifetime
and uh this is it here just you know you
get it and the opportunity of a lifetime
and I agree 100 some of them
you have no idea what was like somebody
were too young I'd go into a Chinese
restaurant
and they had white out on all the menus
I like Chinese food but anyway so one
day rice would be a buck next day be two
bucks and they had to keep writing stuff
out
you know I'm going holy mackerel
and then I put together when I was
flying in Vietnam why my rich dad who
was Chinese said watch out because they
took the dollar off the gold standard
they're going to print money
escort money supply not interest rates
that's exactly what Bert was just saying
right now
so they're going to try and raise
interest rates to slow down the economy
and they're going to exacerbate we're in
a recession already because things are
slowing the velocity of money is slowing
at higher rates of speed
but also it's going to crash the economy
and we may be going into a depression
now oh you're such a bad news guy I tell
you something I learned more in the 70s
than I do today
because when I was when we were I was
trying to put our real estate together
when interest rates are 20 you get
really smart
I mean I had to be creative and all this
and still make it cash flow
so ladies and gentlemen it's only how
smart you know how creative how smart
you are in the future and how
resourceful and resilient you are
because I'm afraid Bert's correct this
is May 2022. I think we're heading into
a depression it's going to be a
recession that's a given we're already
there technically
but a depression is going to be a whole
nother Magilla and some people be wiped
out exactly as Bert says the last
depression gave us communism if you're
poor right now
it was called look in the mirror that
always said to me says if you're looking
in the mirror right now and you see a
loser that's what you are you can't make
money in this economy
you're going to change we are thinking
you know you know hindsight is 2020 as I
said yes yes so I was if you're looking
you know you don't have any money you
don't have a job
your boyfriend or girlfriend has left
you
and uh as soon as I said well how did I
get here
how did I get here it was a it was a
great book called uh you know Gulag
archipelago by Sultan Nathan so he gets
thrown in this in a
um
concentration camp or a gulag in Siberia
and he says how did I get here
you know how you got there
because he was a peacetime leader um
didn't fight back
so people are being sold adult go to
school
get a job pay taxes save money get out
of debt buy a house with a house is an
asset and invest for the long term in a
well-defined portfolio of stocks bonds
mutual funds and ETFs
and I do none of that when you're
putting your team together what are some
things you look for as a team and what
does it take to build a stronger bond
with you it takes time okay yeah you
know because
you know people when it comes to money
people lie
so it takes time to build that trust can
you trust this guy Under Fire that's why
I love the Marine Corps you know we may
not have liked each other if I went into
battle we're all Marines
I could trust so take some time to put a
team together yeah and and a lot of
flakes out there too so like
a couple of my partners we're 40 years
together 40 years together we know each
other like brothers
it's the most important thing to trust
confidence loyalty integrity
diligence
carve on my back there's three kinds of
money today that you guys got to be
aware of one is God's money and God's
money is gold and silver so this is
silver
and this is gold the reason I brought it
most people don't know what it looks
like
and then there's government money which
is fiat currency which is the dollar the
Yen the peso the Euro the Yuan yeah
fake and everybody's working hard for it
it's like eating fake food or drinking
fake water that's why people are getting
sick financially because they're working
for fake money yeah okay
and then there's fake assets which was
another part of their fake Millennial
the fake generation series
but the reason I brought this here is
most people haven't seen it this here is
real silver Plata okay
what it looks like and so in 1972
and this here is gold yeah
this is God's money this is what God's
money looks like yeah the reason I call
it God's money is you can't fake it
you know you can fake it with a fake ETF
like a gold ETF or a silver which I
don't touch because it smells as bad as
the guys have printed that crap
you know what I mean Jesus
but this is real money so
you look at this here
when I first started buying that that
was a dollar 40. yeah
yeah today that's 16 dollars
and this here is Oro Gold
and the reason we brought it is most
people haven't seen or touched this is
real this is God's money why did I say
it's God's money because he was here
when the Earth was created yeah and
it'll be here when we're all dead and
gone when you're saving those fake
dollars this will still be here yeah or
those fake ETFs or those fake stocks
so this here is called the grain box
these are there's 500 of these little
tubes like this wow 500 coins in here
and this is one which is worth more
which one's with more
the gold yeah this is worth more than
all that now the reason I say this is
because for your generation
this could be the biggest opportunity
you'll ever see I'm not making any
commissions on this stuff yeah of course
but if you look at what happened with
the fake Central Bank see the purpose of
the central bank or the fed or all you
know the the Japanese the bank of Japan
or the European Central Bank they pump
out fake money the purpose of central
banks like the FED is to protect the
banks not you
there are criminal operation as far as
I'm concerned
you're going to find that most of my
talks about the Fed
so I would recommend you guys buy this
stuff don't save money
don't save government money because
they're corrupt as hell as you know yeah
save God's money the young people like
you leave school think oh if I know the
right answers then there's no risk and
it drives old guys like me crazy
because everybody's talking about
Millennials what's wrong with them you
know Millennials are the most highly
emitted the most highly educated
generation in history they have the cell
phone they didn't get educated in school
they got educated on social media on the
cell phones
they know all the answers but they're
afraid of doing anything yeah you know
the biggest complaint about my
generation is Millennials know all the
answers but they can't do anything and
the reason they can't do anything is
because you might hurt they're
somebody's feelings you might make a
mistake you know this keeps you guys
just trapped in this little box here
yeah so that's one of the reasons I
think Millennial money is such an
important Point here because if you're
going to come into my world old guys
world or
the information age you've really got to
understand what is risky and what is not
risky and in my world if you play it
safe that makes you stupid
because if you don't take risks you
don't get smarter yeah you know so you
may know the answer but you can't do
anything yeah and one of the best things
I had is I went from I went to military
school then I went to Flight School
I have such great teachers you know all
of them could fly you know so my flight
instructor could fly what a novel idea
you know a flight instructor can fly but
when I was in high school
most of my teachers were
terrified they're all cowards you know
job security don't make mistakes just
memorize the right answer and you'll be
safe and that's why most School teachers
aren't Rich yeah and they teach that to
your generation most of the young people
your age today
and a lot of them want to become
entrepreneurs the problem with this you
have to understand tax
you say this is all over the world very
little difference these guys pay 40
percent of their money in taxes so they
make a thousand dollars they're going to
spend 400 in taxes these guys that make
a thousand dollars they're going to pay
sixty percent in tax
so our schools are teaching
entrepreneurship but then I teach them
tax
okay and because they're focusing on
income
over here
is 20 in tax so they make a thousand
dollars only only two hundred dollars
goes to tax and these guys
zero percent
so the reason Financial education isn't
working in our school systems is they're
teaching Financial education for these
people and these people but to really
become rich you have to focus on this
site here and that's the difference
between Rich Dad and the financial and
what they're teaching in school right
now I'd rather be on this side this side
is a lot harder
but in the long run it's more fun for me
on this side here
it's it's harder but you're paying tax
constantly
so these guys here are saying tax to
Rich well these guys don't pay taxes
and and and as strange as that may seem
and I'm talking about legal this is all
over the world
so that's the big difference here one
last thing which I think most
Millennials understand
is you know in Rich Dad Poor Dad I wrote
about uh Ray Kroc founder of McDonald's
and he was teaching at the University of
Texas the MBA program and Ray asked the
and most of the mbas are going to come
out here
so Ray Kroc asked him he says what
business is McDonald's in
and everybody yelled and said no no we
know you're in hamburgers
and a ray says no we're not I'm not at
McDonald's it's not hamburgers
McDonald's is in the business of Real
Estate
over here
so what you have McDonald's here
and the money McDonald's makes buys the
real estate and that is my formula this
is Rich Dad I own real estate I don't
hang out here I'm glad you guys are here
right and we do our best to make sure
you're educated and you have your own
businesses and things like this here
but really the formula I follow
personally is McDonald's
we have education company that buys real
estate
which means we make a lot of money pay
zero taxes
legally I just know that like your
father you know he went to military
school and I went to military school
and notice the the people that have had
really tough mental emotional physical
and spiritual training they're tougher
yeah yeah so I came out of the I came
out of Academy like your dad he went in
the Navy I went in the Marine Corps and
we come out tougher you know internally
stronger
and I don't know how you guys get that
yeah I mean I
I call it spiritual intelligence at this
point and let me draw this you guys have
seen it before
but again if you look at it this way
this is intelligences
and this is what makes us up this makes
us human beings we have mental
intelligence
we have
physical intelligence
you know like Tiger Woods is a fantastic
golfer I suck you know and then you have
emotional intelligence and emotional
intelligence
they call it EQ is the most important
because I get my feelings hurt all the
time I get angry I you know I I
hallucinate in my head and I think
things that aren't true
but the biggest one of all is the
spiritual
and we're difference between mental
and spiritual
it's very simple mental causes too
so
man woman good bad up down
where spiritual is one so I'll give you
an example
why do I do my work yesterday I was
driving down the road and I saw this
young guy God just broke my heart you
know he's standing there in a hot
Phoenix Sun he's just unemployed
need money to feed the kids and all that
now mentally I could say well get a job
you idiot
but spiritually I I am him
I feel for him yeah
so in my work
I work for this
you know like I don't need the money
yeah
yeah but I as my teacher was Dr R Buck
Minister Fuller
and it says I don't work for me I work
for everyone
and that was one of the biggest lessons
I got from the military you know from
the military was a very high spiritual
intelligence that's why your dad and I
get along so well because when we went
into combat which is a horrible
experience of good and bad people anime
and friends you know
but when we climbed into our aircraft it
was a crew of five
became one
it is the best feeling as horrible as it
is flying into combat because we might
not come back
but it was the highest feeling of all
it was spiritual
and I'm afraid it's not just Millennials
as human beings you know
well you know is this good is this bad
is this the best veton shirt can I get
at a better price or he's cute or she's
cute you know I mean but is there
somebody better
right yeah I mean that's exactly what's
going on so you guys are stuck in your
head and I think it should get more into
your spirit you know like saying what
can I do for my fellow human being yeah
what can I do for the environment
and I think the biggest Secret of My
Success is I I have all you know we all
had these
we all have some degree of physical
things we do yeah
I'm a basket case a lot of the time you
know I get upset I get angry I get sad I
get my feelings hurt
and I'm always this is good this is bad
this is you know you watch politics it's
all good and bad it's a bunch of BS
well what keeps me going is this
and it's spiritual yeah is how can I
serve others how can I serve the planet
how can I fix this problem you know and
Millennials it's not just Millennials
it's as human beings in general if you
can get back to being one
being compassionate
you know
you'll always have idiots here you know
laws of idiots here and idiots here but
just stay in your spirit yeah it's like
when I saw that guy he's probably 45
years old
I couldn't imagine being a father
saying I need money for my kids
and
you know I gave him a few bucks
but it doesn't help no all I was when I
gave him a few bucks I just think hey
we're one yeah I feel your pain
and so what's happening I think it's not
just Millennials it's human human beings
are idiots you know
we inflict a lot of pain
but this is spiritual intelligence
is how do we make it one like my lover
trees when I see people cutting down
trees I want to kill them
you know but and then the oceans you
know it just breaks my heart as I grew
up in the oceans oh yeah
so when we're in our spiritual in our
heart and our Silence of the brain of
the mind that we're most effective if
you understand how money is created
money is credit and debt that's all it
is money credit money I mean credit debt
and taxes that's what money really is
but they don't teach you that in school
so today the reason the world economy is
crashing goes all the way back to 71.
but what happened in 781 they could just
make fake money and they can keep
printing fake money and this is the US
dollar the U.S can keep printing fake
money for a number of years yet and
the only way they could keep the economy
expanding they had to find people stupid
enough to get into debt
so as you know one of the most uh I
didn't have this as a kid
you know it's called a credit card
now everybody has credit cards but they
never teach you how to use it yeah why
do they have a credit card it's because
they needed more money
so they keep expanding the economy they
keep finding people stupid enough to
just get into debt so give them credit
cards and all this and say well he gives
auto loans but I think the most
dastardly thing for your generation was
in 2009
when President Obama uh went to the
banks and said look we need to get the
students more into debt under the guise
of
you need to get a good education that's
why I keep saying to the young the
Millennials you know if they're a pack
of whips
you know I make Millennials who are just
horrifyingly weak snowflakes I call them
you know they go to college at doormats
they taught trigger events or whatever
you know the the I don't know what they
say today but they've got to have
special rooms where there's no whatever
I'm going holy mackerel Welcome to the
Real World you know and there's other
Millennials who are as tough as Nails I
mean this is the biggest opportunity
they've ever had huge so it just depends
upon what's between this year and this
year what's in your heart and that's
what happens often have no basic
Financial education you know whether
you're old or young if you're stupid
you're stupid I mean just don't worry
about it you know the market will take
care of you
and the difference was is that in my
generation it was real estate so I took
real estate courses
I've never lost money in real estate
I've made Fortunes in it do you know I'm
an Insider because I do all my I don't I
don't touch REITs REITs real estate
investment I don't trust paper I am I
handle my own I've started my own gold
mine in China unfortunately the Chinese
took it that was a lesson and I started
my own silver mine in Argentina so I
understand mining
so all of these guys
my friends who are in crypto
they'll tell me they expect about 15
000 new icos
so this you know basically all it takes
is a brain and some electricity in a
computer and you can create your own
crypto so could Bitcoin be toast also
possibly
you know so when I told this guy I
bought Bitcoin when I dropped from 65 to
50. he says it's going to go to five
five dollars I said it might
the difference is I I can afford to lose
that money
but that's called I'm speculating
so this is in my world as a professional
investor I'm in the acquisition phase
I'm taking a position I've taken a
position in Bitcoin and ethereum every
time it looks like it's getting a little
cheaper I'll buy it I'll buy it I'll buy
it so I saw Bitcoin at 20 000 I think it
was and it dropped to seven and I waited
and when it came to nine I bought
so today Allah says 50. I'm still in the
money
and if it goes to 40 I'm going to buy
more now could I be wrong absolutely
could some holding or coin take off yeah
you know could there be another pets.com
of crypto absolutely
but the difference is I'm in the
acquisition of taking a position I took
a position in silver and gold I have
millions not in this country
but I don't have any paper I don't have
any ETFs I only take the real stuff
because as I said the Perth Mint can't
deliver on Silver if a mint can't
deliver on Silver
who do you trust
and so with all of these young kids
coming up going to invent the next
Bitcoin I don't doubt they will
I don't doubt one of those 10 000 new
crypto May blow Bitcoin and ethereum out
of the water and if that happens I'll
make my switch but until then I'm like I
was with gold and silver I'm in
acquisition I've taken a position
when I sell is called distribution so as
a professional I not a speculative and I
don't flip houses because I think that's
really stupid because it's such high
risk to flip a house but today everybody
is flipping houses because the price of
real estate is going through the roof
you know I I was talking to the guy who
cuts my hair says oh I finally bought a
house you know I offered a hundred
thousand over the price and going holy
moly
there's that's a Mania as you know
there's bones bust and Mania real estate
is in a Mania because of this
because interest rates are so low so not
only are stocks going up real estate's
going up
and everybody's jumping in when this
happens the idiots jump in
and that's what's happening right now
so Bitcoin is the same way so when it
took a dip I bought more can it go lower
yes I'll buy more but there's one big
difference between Bitcoin and ethereum
and real estate
Bitcoin and ethereum are liquid
means I can get out if I realize that
there's a new NFC whatever I think what
do they call them or a new guy's going
to take out Bitcoin I can get out but
with real estate the trouble with real
estate if it goes down you're the
skipper of the Titanic you're gonna ride
that baby all the way down
so real estate is not liquid at least
stocks are liquid but that poor bus
driver dropped from liquid stocks
into liquid bonds he's got no place to
go
so when I talked to him about possibly
gold silver or crypto oh
he's an old guy you know he's an old guy
so those are they're all related so in
in this world of money they're all
related
you know it's like
we're all related somehow on this whole
planet and so that's the world of money
today so that's real Financial education
if you realize
you cannot make a prediction especially
today because nobody knows what's going
to happen until it happens
the question is are you prepared for
what it happens so I love Bitcoin
because if I realize there's a hot new
hot new coin coming along I can get out
but in real estate I'm stuck in it so
those are some of the differences
between investors acquisition taking a
position and distribution
I can distribute my Bitcoin and gold and
silver quickly I cannot distribute my
real estate that quickly or my
businesses so those are some of the
differences in as real Financial
Education First word I had to learn at
the Marine at the Academy mission
mission is spiritual that's your mission
and my mission has always been to serve
people
most people all they give up is making
money and throwing people
that's called the Federal Reserve Bank
Wall Street and all that I wanted to do
with them
so I just don't play their game but you
have to get smarter not to play their
game the thing I've said before and I'll
say it again because some people need to
hear it your generation this thing
called life was my cell phone didn't
come out until 2007.
yeah millennial generation was given the
most powerful single tool ever given to
any generation
and what are you guys using this thing
for to Twitter to you know social I
don't know what you guys do with this
thing but I love this thing I mean I'm
I'm on YouTube constantly you know I
find the best teachers in the world out
there I mean
I don't know why and I would go to
college because the best teachers are on
YouTube for free and I learned and it's
not that the teacher is the best the
thing I love about YouTube is I can get
one person says X and the Guyana says no
that's why and so I'll listen to both
sides but that's where your intelligence
grows because both sides have a point of
view and I listen to both sides but if
you're in college you gotta listen to
One idiot who's boring you know I really
did not like school you can tell yeah
first of all is I didn't want to become
an employee and I returned the teacher
says go to school and get a job and I
said
but I don't want a job you know and it
didn't make sense to me because I had a
rich dad my poor dad was an employee he
was a good one but personally I didn't
want to become an employee
but your generation now must that's the
difference yeah you must you don't have
that option A lot of people say well how
come my kids kick in my butt is that
because of because they don't have
breaks put on you you know kids just
make mistakes
parents still have what they were
programmed to think don't make mistakes
make sure everything you know I mean
they're slower kids are faster
and so they learn faster so I learned
you know when I was 10 my rich dad
started teaching me
about entrepreneurship and investing
with the game of Monopoly and you know I
said Simon Says and my poor dad the
academics going what you doing it's like
I play Monopoly
and he says well that's a waste of time
you know go back and study that's why he
says well ask ask your friends father
Rich Dad why are you studying Monopoly
and so I asked Rich to ask why are we
studying Monopoly he says because one of
the greatest formulas of wealth is found
in this game board idiot says what is
I'm 10 years old going like this four
greenhouses 10 31 tax deferred exchange
into a red Hotel
I guess and so I'm a kid boy at my old
man the PhD from Stanford and all this
stuff you know and he's broke is broke
is broke and Rich Dad goes from his
little dinky little store and now the
property owns is called the Hyatt
Regency on Waikiki Beach so he followed
the four Korean houses one red hotel and
again the greatest educator of our times
could have been Maria Montessori who
said what the hand does the Mind
remembers so my rich dad for my
education he says you want a real
education kid
oh of course of course so you owned
my father called poor Day called slums
my rich text I'm a low-income housing
provider that means his definitions he
says they'll knock on doors and collect
rent
what what
you know so that's what everybody wants
to invest in real estate but I don't
want to collect rent or fix the toilet
you know what I mean so I'm 10 year old
10 to 12 I'm
uh your rent is due
that I heard more abolished
[Laughter]
these are grown adults like Hey kid beat
it up you know I don't have my it's you
it's you signs of a you
capitalists from 10 years old and so we
can't afford it they got big screen TV
in the room they're watching TV
but they can't pay the rent
and they have kids
what are they teaching their kids
knocking on doors
asking grown-ups for overdue rent
fried my brains
that I don't want to be like I find the
best teachers on YouTube they're not you
know
uh they they teach because they want to
teach but some of them are Crooks too
well you're going to know the difference
and so I think YouTube is fantastic and
I'm on YouTube constantly so you saw me
take off my headsets and all this I go
to sleep with YouTube on but I choose my
teachers wisely
so who are some good teachers people can
watch I listen to guys who who hate each
other
this may sound strange but pewter Schiff
hates Bitcoin he's a good friend of mine
he's a gold guy then I listen to Michael
Saylor and all these other guys who are
Bitcoin guys and and uh so I just
listened to the two points of view
because in between there is
something I can take away but I don't
listen to just one side
that's why I said when I was in 1911
well 9 13 I was in Istanbul talking to
Muslims I said I want to find out about
your religion because I was told what I
was told as a marine you know the
Crusades all our infidels and all this
crap that we're taught as Marines also
and I said you guys are good people
they're good people today you have most
of these people who have a financial
plan and they want you to give them
their money you know put your money in
stock spots mutual funds ETF and savings
okay you know
and most of that money is gone anyway as
we talked about earlier the last two
years of most people's lives all that
money disappears anyway
so what's the end game for Kim and I
here and for Kim and I our end game
is the end financial plan is this money
goes into what's called
a CRT a charitable remainder Trust
this charitable remainder trust then
means the government can't tax me that's
the reason and you know and you're going
to study taxes the only people that pay
taxes are these people here because
they're not doing what the government
wants
over here I'm a partner with the
government the reason I get a tax break
here is because I provide jobs these
guys don't provide jobs
I got a tax break here because I invest
in real estate most people have a house
I have thousands of houses and we
provide housing I provide oil you know
so I'm I get the tax breaks because the
government's my partner
if you go to school and get a job over
here you will pay those tax
and you should because you're not doing
what the government wants I do what the
government wants so at the end of our
lives here we're going to put it here
into a CRT
and the goal is
the government can't tax that money and
it goes out in our for Kim and I
our goal is every year we're going to
give a hundred million to charity every
year
most people will be broke at the end of
their lives
so we're going to give all this money
back
and for inter-perpetuity
Charities that we support like I'm I'm
very much into the oceans so I support
Greenpeace
Kim loves animals so she supports
animals we support all these things that
we can't do because we're working our
businesses
so we give our money back to Charities
we give it to Boys and Girls Clubs and
other Charities all over the world
a hundred million dollars for a lot of
people you know like Trump not a lot of
money for us it's a lot of money
so 100 million dollars here is our goal
today
we're probably if if if I died and Kim
died today it'll probably be
25 million a year
but I have probably another 10 years 20
years to live so my this is the ultimate
goal Kim has probably another 30 years
so can we make this most likely
and if we don't make it we're still at
25 million today
but that's the end game here we just
give it back and because we give it back
the government doesn't tax us
that's why I love the tax law the
difference is is when I left my high pay
I so I got a job with Xerox
so that's the last job I ever had so
when you look at the cash flow quadrant
here
a s b i
here I was okay and I was making a lot
of money at Xerox I went to Xerox for
one thing not the money
I worked at xerox's I had to learn how
to sell
um because entrepreneurs have to learn
how to sell so I Was preparing for this
quadrant here yeah
but I was really preparing for the big
business quadrant so I took a job at
Xerox for four years so I Was preparing
for these two quadrants here so when I
talked to young people like you look
like you're here in social media yeah
you're learning the same thing I was
learning at Xerox except you're learning
technology wise yeah it's very smart 100
that's and that's exactly what I'm doing
here and one thing I actually really do
appreciate when I worked at the bank was
that we were very sales orientated
orientated and that's all that mattered
and I think that's where I got a lot of
my sales skills too correct like it was
learning and learning how to get
rejected and finding a way to not get
rejected next time so the lesson to
young people is don't take a job for the
money take a job for what you're
learning yeah you know and the harder
and it was really hard because I didn't
like I'm actually a very shy person so
learning how to sell was the hardest
thing I could do
but if I hadn't spent four years
learning how to sell I never made it
here I never made it here so the entire
time that you were here you were
preparing to jump to the other classes
correct so every job is not so much for
the high paying job with job security
for not not everybody and most people
should have job security because
they're not designed to be entrepreneurs
but if you're going to be an
entrepreneur then you better take this
job and say well which way am I going to
go yeah
so I knew
my job at Xerox
was to go here and here and here yeah
not stay here and I actually make so
much money over here that I don't need
job security
so really that's the lesson when you
look at a job you look at what can I
learn more than how much can I make and
I think that's the biggest challenge and
if you look for a job where you can
learn a lot
the heart of the job the better it is
yeah do you know yeah and the sad thing
today is
those guys my age all guys
who should be retired
but they can't afford to retire so
they're going back looking for a job
last night I was talking to this
Vietnamese guy he he lost his job with a
telecom company he was a computer
programmer
so the set is saying on this guy I made
nice guy probably a few years younger
than me he's now working three jobs
because in his head I mean he was a high
paid executive of the telecon company
and he lost his job the companies out of
business I won't mention his name yeah
but he still has go to school get a job
it's still running his head here
rather than say
what can I learn
and today I mean it's really sad I was
having coffee yesterday and this guy
comes up to me he said about my age he
says can I come to your company and
apply for a job
I said man you're as old as I am
but he I said
he says I just don't want any
problems I just want the paycheck well
most successful entrepreneurs have gone
bust
right you know Henry Ford an old-time
entrepreneur he went bus five times
okay look at Steve Jobs he's on board
fired him yeah you know Bill Gates was
taken before The Supreme Court for
monopolistic practices right even my
friend Donald Trump went down a billion
dollars yeah I only went down a million
so the average person is so afraid of
those losses they never get ahead
because at school they teach you if you
make a mistake or if you fail you're a
failure but that's not real life a baby
learns to walk by standing up and
falling down standing up and falling
down
and our school system punishes you for
making mistakes that's why my poor dad
an academic was so unsuccessful he was
terrified of making mistakes so once
again is
your generation you've got more faith to
Wade through and to think of what's real
so today's Millennial money is fake rich
people and from my world you know I
started with absolutely nothing
and I've run in in my lifetime some of
the most dangerous people on earth
are fake rich people
and in my world which is money
how do you know if somebody giving
advice is real
or fake
so when I go back to you because your
generation is also called Millennials
The Bling generation right yeah it's all
about what you wear and how you act and
portraying this life of Living our best
lives and so traveling buying purses of
name brands well how about these guys
who have 500 sneakers on yeah and and
like you know I used to work at a bank
so you would see this person come in
with this lavish car and this like their
Gucci belt and their Valentino shoes and
had probably about 50 bucks in the bank
account so it's like either their
knockoffs or you really don't know how
to use your money
so one of the reasons you want to know
about fake rich people is I would say
95 percent of Americans are fake Rich
yeah they may have you know a nice big
house the Beamer or whatever they got
and all this they might have the fake
Rolex or the fake this on but
um I mean how much time does your
generation talk about
bling like purses and stuff like that
and I think we're in the generation
where we fit perfectly with Keeping Up
With the Jones and so I think it's more
important for a person for an average
Millennial how they look and this life
that they appear to be living then how
financially healthy they actually are
the problem with many people in my
generation is they look rich
but they're fake Rich so the first thing
that most guys or men and women buy is
the big house
so these rock stars football started by
that's fake rich
then they drive nice cars
and you know I have my roles sitting out
here I have my Ferraris I love nice cars
and then they have a lot of bling yeah
but that's a very very poor person
so the thing is how does a young person
know especially if you're looking for a
spouse or a partner and all this and in
business also
my biggest challenge in business
was that I had a lot of business
partners who are fake rich
that nothing
but they live in the big neighborhoods
and all this is one one partner said to
me she says
you only make a hundred thousand a year
I said yeah she goes
and I went but the hundred thousand came
from the asset side so a hundred
thousand came from assets
going into my income
and what they had is they had no assets
but her husband
had a uh you know the high paying
job yeah and so their cash flow pattern
went like this most went to taxes
and then they Supply this big house and
all this
and then they had their kids in private
schools yeah
so when you're driving around the
neighborhoods looking at so-called rich
people
you know most of them aren't Rich
they're actually one paycheck away from
disaster
so if you talk to young men or young
women whatever you guys are into is here
is you want to talk about assets so
that's my wife and Kim and I talk about
all the time as our assets
our minds as I've said this before and
ever
is in the asset column
the average person the middle class
person their mind's on liability column
so it's a young woman today
I strongly suggest keep your mind in the
asset column because I know what when I
was your age a lot of it was just
handling expenses right was to rent food
clothing just medical bills yeah
everything and then the the biggest
mistake many young people make is
they want a high paying job
and the trouble of the high paying job
is most of them wind up here
in the liability column
but Robert I mean you have a Rolls-Royce
sitting outside in your Ferrari out here
too so what does that mean
well I like the nice life too okay but
this is the difference in financial IQ
Financial intelligence because I think
one of the most stupid things people say
to young people live belong your means
do I love bologna means no
nobody wants to live I don't either yeah
so adult that's a poor person okay so
this is the difference and why we have
the Rich Dad company
and why I wrote the book fake and Rich
Dad portrayed the cash flow game it goes
to this okay
so here's my ruler
and I have I've had six Ferraris I love
nice cars
again this is my Paddock you know and
all this stuff I love and they're all
real I don't know fake Rolls-Royce out
there
so the question is how does somebody
have this stuff so that's what most of
the so-called
fake financial advisors will live below
your means what looks sweetheart I love
my Rolls-Royce you know
I love my Ferrari I may be Japanese but
I look better in Ferraris and Toyotas
you know what I mean
is fake advice
if you really want to have the nice
things of life
Focus again
on assets so the deal I have with my
wife Kim
is I can have any cut anything I want
but my asset
must pay for that
so the rule of thumb that Kim and I have
as a couple
is that if I want a new Rolls Royce a
new Ferrari new boat and you have
anything any liability
I buy the asset first then it buys the
Rolls Royce
So What by what's buying my Rolls Royce
right now is I have apartment houses and
golf courses I just focus here and I can
anything I want here
so for young Millennials like you
Focus here
or you can focus here if you focus here
okay you want so the reason games are
the best teachers at least Monopoly was
for me and our board game cash flow
because I created cash flow is a game
will engage me mentally
I'm interested it gets me emotionally
yeah nobody likes to lose you know
and then physically I have to do
something I have I like the board game
better than electronic game because I
have to do the math yeah you know what I
mean when you do the math you're
actually getting smarter and then it's
spiritually it's you want I want to make
sure you win and I can I don't have to
take you out to win cash flow that's
what I mean I don't have to I don't have
to make you the loser but that's what
schools do they have to have one person
smart one person's stupid one winner one
loser
so what I'm teaching you either real
estate or business and all this I don't
want you to lose I want you to win
so once again the games are the better
teachers like the game of Monopoly
simply because it involves you your
physical intelligence and the more you
do your numbers on the cash flow game
the smarter you get
emotionally because nobody likes to lose
this is really surprising a lot of
people lose because they got too happy
do what I mean yeah no what happened oh
I'm rich
then I get egotistical and arrogant you
know I got cocky and I'm smarter I'm
richer than you lose
and you also lose if you've been told
why I'm stupid I failed at all this
stuff you also lose
so that's why games are the best
teachers because you go up and down
emotionally as you're playing the game
but spiritually as we get together to
help each other out yeah we're one the
reason I say only lazy people use their
own money is because it takes much more
intelligence to raise capital
and so I've never been able ever since
my rich dad's as a little boy my Rich
Dad forbade me if I'm ever saying I
can't afford it
he says figure out how you can afford it
how can you do something figure out how
you can do something
so over my lifetime most of the projects
I I've started I've I've never had
anybody I like not having money because
it forces me to think I get creative I
have to educate myself I have to talk to
Rich guys hey how did you do this how
did you do that how do you do that and
what has happened to me and I just
turned 72. I've never needed money
because if I need money I figure out how
to raise it you know Millennials are the
most highly emitted it's the most highly
educated generation in history they have
the cell phone they didn't get educated
in school they got educated on social
media on the cell phones
they know all the answers but they're
afraid of doing anything yeah you know
the biggest complaint about my
generation is Millennials know all the
answers but they can't do anything and
the reason they can't do anything is
because it might hurt their somebody's
feelings you might make a mistake you
know that's just keeps you guys just
trapped in this little box here yeah so
that's one of the reasons I think
Millennial money is such an important
Point here because if you're going to
come into my world old guys world or
the information age you've really got to
understand what is risky and what is not
risky and in my world if you play it
safe
that makes you stupid
because if you don't take risks you
don't get smarter yeah you know so you
may know the answer but you can't do
anything yeah and one of the best things
I had is I went from I went to military
schools I went to flight school I had
such great teachers you know all of them
could fly you know so my flight
instructor could fly what a novel idea
you know a flight instructor can fly but
when I was in high school
most of my teachers were
terrified they're all cowards you know
job security don't make mistakes just
memorize the right answer and you'll be
safe and that's why most School teachers
aren't Rich yeah and they teach that to
your generation yeah the irony of us you
know when I was when I left school in
the 60s there were plenty of jobs
but the world has changed yeah and our
schools haven't
and so they're still making this innate
promise of get a job
and I was very fortunate when I
graduated in 69 we're the highest paid
graduates in the world my classmates
were making about 120 to 150 000 a year
that's not much money today
but 1969 that was a lot of money
but natural as young guys do we spent
every penny of it
yeah so I had my rich dad's lesson the
rich don't work for money in my head I
said okay
I'm making all this money I have a
secure job
but what's beyond that and that's where
education comes in
so if I could explain this to you for
the for the rest of the millennial
lessons it's really going to be on this
theme Here
because Financial education is about not
working for money like one of the first
questions when I finally realized what
my rich dad was saying I said well when
do I never need a paycheck again
see my goal wasn't you know
go to the moon or
you know secure cancer my job was when
when I never need a paycheck again
because as long as you need a paycheck
be it from an employer or like my poor
dad he was so afraid of losing his
government pension yeah
I'm going Jesus what a way to run your
life your pension so my old man kind of
kind of got fired he lost his pension
it was the most frightening thing in the
world to him he had no pension then it
was Social Security which is even worse
so that's why my goal when I was about
Ura is a little older around 25 I said
my goal is to never need a paycheck
again from anybody
even the government I don't want any
Medicare Social Security
or whatever you know I was a military
pilot I said oh you got to get the
military pilot pension I said you do but
I'm not going to and just because of
this here that was the difference
because I never wanted to work for money
to need a paycheck so the next few
lessons in Millennial money you'll find
out what I do work for
so for right now just let me go to the
lesson here
[Applause]
so this comes from Rich Dad Poor Dad and
this these are some of the distinctions
it was the advantage I had at age nine
because I knew what I wanted to work for
and this here in simple terms is called
a financial statement in school they
teach you get a FICO score FICO is BS
all it means how good are you paying
your bills that's all FICO means okay
should be the Fido score good dog
so this is what your Banker wants to see
so when I was nine years old playing
Monopoly with my Rich Dad this is the
lesson that's not included in Monopoly
but rich dad taught me
and fundamentally the problem
that most people make they go to school
to get a job
and they work here so this is the poor
middle class in these guys
and we're going to talk about later your
first line item expense is taxes
you know just recently president Trump
said he had a tax cut
he didn't have a tax cut for these guys
as you know the rules are always written
for the rich okay
I didn't make the rules you can get
angry at me but these are the rules the
rich make the rules the Golden Rule who
he who has a gold makes the rules yeah
so the tax cut went to people here
that's where it goes and you learn more
about this later on but this is what I
work for
so what I work for number one is I'm an
entrepreneur I want businesses I have
multiple businesses
and I don't work in them as you know
because you work here you never see me
do it no
because I don't work for a paycheck
exactly next is real estate and real
estate is good for many things which
will go into but number one is debt I
use a lot of debt to buy real estate and
I pay no taxes that's the relationship
there the Nexus paper
and that's saving stocks bars mutual
funds ETFs and that stuff I don't have
any of that stuff I don't save money I
don't know that
but this is what most people have to go
to school get a job
get a 401k and save money
loser
I'm doing that just to upset you guys
because maybe you'll start to think
because I didn't make the rules I'm just
telling these are the rules these people
pay the highest taxes
and they work the hardest and the last
are commodities
four different asset classes so
Commodities are number one is gold
silver oil Land water food
so this is what I work for when I left
school rather than working for a
paycheck
and working for money
my education had to go beyond getting a
job which I had a good job
but I now had to start when I left
school about your age
the thing I have I focused on first
actually was commodities
so back in 1972 I started buying gold
and it was illegal for Americans to own
gold you can imagine that
back in 72.
today you have Bitcoin it's different
okay everything is changing so rapidly
today so I started with gold
but actually the next thing was actually
oil because I went to school to be a
tanker officer driving ships for
standard oil
so I understand oil so I own my wife and
I don't own standard oil or Chevron or
Exxon we own oil wells again
taxes you got no tax breaks for wanting
paper oil
huge tax base for owning real oil
and then I went into real estate
why because I can use debt to buy real
estate and because I use debt
I pay no taxes
and then third I started my business my
first real rail business I had many many
businesses as a kid
but my first real business was a nylon
and velcro Surfer while at business
and I went worldwide right away the
trouble is I was an idiot
and the business went up and the
business came down what kept me alive
was this and this
okay
so you may say why aren't you working
for money but we'll go under that next I
don't want what's called
a paycheck
I want cash flow
so that's what I mean by the rich don't
work for money
you want cash flow that pays very little
taxes and I can use lots of debt over
here the average person who went to
school their biggest liability to have
is student loans of course yeah of
course definitely
I mean it's horrible what they do to you
guys today
you have student loan which is the worst
type of debt of all because you cannot
declare bankruptcy on it
then you get out you try and buy a house
and you call it an asset when it's
really a liability why because the cash
is Flowing that way
your house costs you money everybody you
rent a house still costs you money
okay then you have to have a nice car I
had one of those
so the problem with most young people is
they go to school to get that job
then a lot of it has student loan debt
then they try and get married and buy a
house they have a car
and then they have credit card debt
but they never have the chance to come
over here if they do any investing in
America it's a 401k
which I wouldn't touch with a 10-foot
pole um you should but I don't because I
don't have to
because I went to school for here
and people who don't go to school should
be here this is a 401k Ira
ETFs and that's the paper
savings I don't touch that stuff and
we'll go into that later on okay
so when I say a rich don't work for
money I never want to be dependent on a
paycheck either from an employer
or the government I want to be a free
human being my teacher was Dr R
Buckminster Fuller
and it says I don't work for me I work
for everyone
and that was one of the biggest lessons
I got from the military you know from
the military was a very high spiritual
intelligence that's why your dad and I
get along so well because when we went
into combat which is a horrible
experience of good and bad people anime
and friends you know
but when we climbed into our aircraft it
was a crew of five we became one
it is the best feeling as horrible as it
is
flying into combat because we might not
come back
but it was the highest feeling of all
it was spiritual
and I'm afraid it's not just Millennials
as human beings you know
well you know is this good is this bad
is this the best vitone shirt am I can I
get at a better price or he's cute or
she's cute you know I mean but is there
somebody better right yeah I mean that's
exactly what's going on so you guys are
stuck in your head and I think you
should get more into your spirit you
know like saying what can I do for my
health fellow human being yeah what can
I do for the environment
and I think the biggest Secret of My
Success is I I have all you know we all
had these
we all have some degree of physical
things we do yeah
emotionally I'm a basket case a lot of
the time you know I get upset I get
angry I get sad I get my feelings hurt
and I'm always this is good this is bad
this is you know you watch politics it's
all good and bad it's a bunch of BS
but what keeps me going is this
and it's spiritual yeah is how can I
serve others how can I serve the planet
in my world I said I see people they
chase shiny objects
and what what a shiny object means is
you know when you're fishing you throw a
lower this little shiny obstacles and
the fish comes in where they jump in
it's what most people do Bitcoin today
is a shiny object I'm not saying you
can't make a lot of money in it but most
people are chasing shiny objects they
want to make money
they're not building an asset here
the thing the reason I don't do it here
this is the highest risk
now
this is what I know the higher the risk
the more education it takes for example
if I wanted to learn how I flew if I
wanted to just fly my little Cessna 172
around the place not much risk in that
but when I had to go to Vietnam to fly
the risk went up I had to study harder
become better work harder at it
the reason most people stay in paper
401ks IRAs and chasing shiny objects
like Bitcoin is because they don't want
to take the risk here they're huge
you've got to study that's why I've ever
studies education Rich dad's coaching
all of you guys are allowed to take
courses and all this
if you come here it takes no
intelligence to be here
it takes no intelligence to buy Bitcoin
I mean I have four four Bitcoin no five
Bitcoin it didn't take you know I just I
don't have to do anything
over here well I have to know a lot over
here I've known a lot
I have to study
so if you want a shiny object like the
stock market and all that you can make
get rich there
it's really easy to get in here it's
really hard here
and comments other questions does that
make sense they're chasing shiny objects
so I do agree with you when you talk
about Bitcoin being a shiny object that
everybody's chasing right and one of my
favorite stories that you've told is
about your Mentor Frank when he sent you
to Peru so you could learn a valuable
lesson about maybe something that wasn't
such a shiny object and turned in to be
because shiny objects change every day
so I wanted to learn about I didn't have
icos initial coin offerings I want to
learn about eye peels initial public
offering and it's how you take a
business and turn it into paper
you turn it into stock
so I wanted to say my friend Frank who
was Hardcore here on how many companies
he started taking public
and I said Frank he didn't know me from
Adam I said I want to learn to do an IPO
he goes yeah you and everybody else he
said most guys don't have it they don't
have the guts they don't have the
determination and they're wimps
I said I want to learn he says how bad
this is up here in Scottsdale Arizona
I said badly he says okay this is
Wednesday Bia Lima Peru on Saturday I
went
on Saturday
and we were shooting the our video for
the Cash Flow game you know
he says how bad do you want it
I said badly
he says I'll you know you meet my
president in Lima Frank never traveled
you meet my president in Lima and I'll
find out how bad you want it
so that was Wednesday Wednesday night I
was on a plane to Lima Peru I had to pay
full boat I paid my own way most
employees can't stand that because they
don't have any money
I flew into Lima Peru I went to look at
three gold mines
and with Frank's president it was an
experience an education I've never had I
would never have I didn't show it up
it cost me probably fifteen to twenty
thousand dollars just for airfare on
that thing I get back on Tuesday to talk
to Frank and I said Frank
there's nothing there he says I could
have told you that
so why'd you send me
oh the fan how badly you want to learn
since most people don't have it
they want a job they want job secure
they want a paycheck they want a 401k
and that's why they don't get to come
here that's why they don't get to come
over here right or wrong you know
I don't ever want to be here I knew I
know it's your age I want to come here
but the higher the risk the higher the
returns but also the higher dedication
education and study you have to go
through so today
and I'm making millions and millions I
make more in a day than most people make
in a lifetime
but it was worth it
did I lose sometimes yes but it was
worth it
you go to school here you take no risk
that's why my poor dad was poor he
didn't like to make mistakes
the differences between what they're
teaching in school and what we at Rich
Dad teach so this this is the very big
difference like I said most School
teachers
are like my poor dad
and this was actually this was Rich Dad
Poor Dad what you're seeing here is a
financial statement
You Know Rich Dad Porter has a book on
accounting the most boring subject on
planet Earth but book number two of Rich
Dad was this one here
and this was called the cash flow
quadrant right you have e
s
B and I so test for you what does e
stand for employee good and what the
employees always say that they work for
money
but they want job security exactly
paycheck and pension yes okay what does
s stand for self-employed they're small
business owners yes doctors lawyers they
work for tips they work for tips now so
they're self-employed and b stands for
what big business owners so 500
employees or more yeah and I stands for
what the investor investor it's more
than just investor it's Insider
you see this is like Shark Tank on the
TV shows these guys here have done this
and have done this
so this was my poor dad this site this
was Rich Dad here
so the difference that's what schools
are not teaching you is what's the
difference between these people and
these people
that's the big difference and that shows
up so when I was about your age I had to
make a decision did I want to as a pilot
you know my most of my friends want to
fly for the airlines but I'd be here
or I could be a you know I could have a
little I could be an Alaska flying
fisherman around the place you know a
private a pilot with a small plane and
you know flying around the place
or I could own an Airlines or I could
invest in Airlines and that's the
difference in the mindsets and skill
sets you don't just make Crossings the
education is extremely different on this
side than on this side here the reason I
wrote fake is because
it's about fake money yeah so that was
1971. Nixon took the dollar off the
goals did it what else Nixon did
in 7a4 he opened the door to China
and today all the jobs left America
another thing that that Nixon did he
created the 401K
fake pension
so in the 1970s when I was about your
age that's when the world was changing
so fake money
fake teachers did the teachers ever tell
us that no never and they still don't
yeah you know the teachers are such a
waste of time you know I mean their
education is important about what are
they teaching you
so it's fake money fake teachers and
fake assets
so the reason about Rich Dad Poor Dad
and I wrote this book Rich dad's
prophecy and fake they're all saying the
same thing is
you know whether you went to college or
not this one thing is guaranteed if
we're lucky we're going to get old
right yeah and I don't know if you know
but your father tells a story when he
retired from the Navy how much was his
pension his pension was probably 50
bucks a month 50 bucks a month and he
was paying for my parents my
grandparents health care costs right
that wasn't even enough for the plate
that of plate of food that day yeah so
for the Millennials you guys it's even
worse because you probably won't have a
pension yeah the ayakani on Social
Security not at all and I think many
people are so look look at this chart
here this is social security it goes
bust now
it's bust Medicare is bust
one of the saddest things about America
today is not only are we a biggest
debtor nation in the world
but when I was your age only 20 percent
of our budget went to entitlements today
in America it's 75 percent
we have all of these people saying the
government should take care of me which
leads to ALC and
of Elizabeth Warren and ComEd Sanders
they all want the government to take
care of them just as we're going bust
so that's why we created the Rich Dad
company because it'll give your give
somebody like you a chance your
generation's toast I hate to say that
this is worldwide pensions are broke all
over the world
we I was just in Romania talking to
these young guys that said
everybody stole all the money of our
pensions
and that was in Rich Dad and fake
fake assets they steal your money
through your money in your assets
yeah it's a horrible horrible thing yeah
and we grew up with the sense of
entitlement because that's what we've
been taught as of today and and what
really frightens me is that people still
talk about their pensions and soon our
the parents people who have parents who
have been depending on this pension are
soon going to find out it's not going to
be there and so I mean what's going to
happen why why is it that no one's
talking about the fact that it's
underfunded by seven trillion dollars
it's actually 17 trillion 17 trillion
but we're all right at 77 trillion
so this pension problem is the biggest
problem that faces the world
and the reason is our school system is
complicit you know they're in cahoots
with
the banks so that's why I wrote Rich
dad's prophecy in 2002 it was about a
thing called the 401K so again that
started back in 1970 again with Nixon
and all this stuff so when I was your
age there was a thing called the
three-legged stool
and what they said was for my generation
you would have savings
you would have social security
and you would have a pension a 401k or
something
guess what
God
your generation
doesn't have this even
okay that's the challenge
so that's why the rich daddy company was
formed I said I wrote this in 2002 and I
said the biggest crash was going to come
in 2016. the reason it didn't come
because I started this book in 1999 I
didn't see quantitative easing I didn't
see all this printing money coming so if
I was teaching a bunch of high school
kids I said when you leave school here
today the big question in your mind is
what kind of income do I want for the
rest of my life well
I wanted passive
and the average person because they have
a job is working for earned income which
is the highest tax you get tired working
for that so when you look at again the
Rich Dad financial statement here
income expense assets and liabilities
okay so earned income
is this here
that's earned
okay
when you when you work for and then the
problem with that income is tax
then the if you're working for a
portfolio income
you're generally working for this you
buy a stock for let's say Apple for 10
bucks
and it goes to 50 bucks and you sell it
the trouble with that again is X
but if you're working for passive income
but your mom and dad work for is this is
passive income here
okay as cash flow it's also called so
that's what the cash flow board game
pictured here
so all I wanted was passive income so
what I have today is I have about 7 000
rental properties I have hotels golf
courses oil and all this
but again it goes back to these three
types of income earn portfolio and
passive so if I was talking to a bunch
of high school kids
or even elementary school kids it's not
that hard yeah
but I'm glad you asked the question
because I think a lot of a lot of young
people can think they'll say well why am
I in school
I don't know
you know if you just want to work hard
and pay taxes on earned income
and flip real estate or flip houses then
you're working for portfolio yeah
I don't flip
yeah that's a very big difference I
don't like to buy low and sell High
that's flipping
that's called capital gains which is
portfolio I invote for cash flow which
is passive
and I can turn cap I can turn capital
gains into passive I mean it's so
it gets crazier and crazier and crazier
from there on but I'm glad you asked the
question Kim and I retired she was 37
and I was 47 10 years apart took us 10
years
but all we did was get richer after that
because we found our formula and our
formula wasn't go to school get a job or
a card save money get out of debt and
invest in the stock market that wasn't
our nothing wrong with that format it
just wasn't our formula what was your
formula
play Monopoly yeah four greenhouses red
hotel and the McDonald's formula of our
you know as Ray Kroc said we found that
McDonald's McDonald's is in the business
of Real Estate
and as and paying no taxes mm-hmm so
that's when so anyway
when Tom and Kenny and the other
advisors come here
their job is going to twist your brain
to see it differently
does that make sense to you yeah it's
going to be a whole mind shift of what
we've been taught and very
non-traditional ways where sometimes
when you think about not paying taxes or
using debt it's like what are you even
talking about how right and that's
dangerous because you've been taught to
pay taxes and get out of debt
brainwashed yeah right
so what's what what I'm what I'm glad
you're starting on here as you bring in
my advisors in remember advisors are my
teachers then that's just telling me
what to do they're not experts we work
together we plan together
right now Tom and IO and Kenny because
Kenny is who I I invest through using
debt
and Tom would advise me on taxes
so that my game I play is not be a good
employee
and work hard and pay taxes
my game is to be a capitalist
to have my money and Investments work
hard for me so I can make millions and
millions of dollars and pay no tax now
that drives a lot of people crazy right
and Rich Dad Poor Dad I said Savers are
losers and guess what they are you know
today it's coming soon
we're going to have negative interest
rates I don't know how they can do that
but if you deposit a hundred dollars in
the bank when I was a kid I got 15
interest
so I put a hundred dollars in the bank
and a year later I got 115 dollars
today you put a hundred dollars in the
bank you've got to pay the bank fifteen
dollars
and and they're printing it so the the
value of the dollar is going down but
the the price of keeping the bank keeps
going up they charge you to keep your
money in the bank tell me why would you
save money
so that's why way back when 25 years ago
the Savers are losers
I also said your house is not an asset
and then 2008 the market crash well it's
kind of crashing again because
everybody's going into real estate right
now now the good news is that the people
are moving out of the big cities like
New York Chicago San Francisco Los
Angeles and they're moving into smaller
towns well what that does in the smaller
towns it drives the price of real estate
up so again it pushes out the lower you
know if you live in po do not you you're
a little dinky town you don't make as
much money as the guy's moving in from
Chicago
and and I was up I was you know I own a
piece of property up in northern Arizona
and my friends in real estate there are
just laughing they're saying oh these
guys from California come in you know a
house I bought for a hundred thousand
they're paying me 400 000 for
they're all happy
well for the Californian they sold a
four million dollar house so they can
fire it for a hundred thousand dollar
property so that's Market it's all
convoluted going all over the place and
all this
people are excited Kim just sold their
mom's house in Hilton Head South
Carolina these people came out of New
Jersey and there was a bidding war for
the house
so there's all kinds of things going on
in real estate today but it'll
eventually crash simply because the
government is making it so expensive to
build a house so one of the reasons my
niche market with Kenny McElroy in real
estate we only buy existing property
because it costs too much to do you know
the permits and fees and all that it
costs so much to develop a piece of
property so once again the Millennials
get screwed because the price of
property gets more expensive but you got
less house
tonight this is so screwed up but that's
what happens when the government steps
in
and they kick capitalists out and then
the Socialists kick in but anyway that's
why Sabers are losers tonight be careful
for those who are not paying attention
in other words we're about to go into
What's called the Wiley Coyote moment
everybody's running a lot of says oh
don't worry the fed's got my back you
know the economy is fine I love this guy
Biden you know and where America is the
greatest the economy is safe I was a
and when people crash when this thing
crashes and it's coming soon
it's the people that are not prepared
the people who are not watching this
emergency podcast number three haven't
watched number two or number one
are the ones you're gonna have to be
afraid of
be very very afraid of those who are
sound asleep at this moment because when
they wake up they're going to wonder
what happened
so I'll just tell you a quick story
I went to flight school you know to fly
these things in Vietnam
and they wanted to prepare us for the
worst
so how did they prepare you for the
worst well they make it the worst
so what they do is they take us out into
the Gulf of Mexico off of Pensacola
Beach
they assimilate a parachute crashing
into the ocean so it's freezing weather
I think the temperature was minus three
degrees or something we hang out the
back we drop into the water we gotta
unhook
then we paddle us through our little
rubber ducks you know there's like seven
of us in a group and we go ashore into
the swaps of Florida
and our job is to survive so it's a
similar crashing in Vietnam or the
jungles
and then we had to figure out how to
survive so everything is like a little
boy scout camp the first day everybody's
happy you know we're chugging along this
is this is easy this is easy day two
gets a little bit more serious
then day three we're hungry
and this is what I'm talking about it
took us till day three
to turn into animals we went primal
I I was ready to kill the guy next to me
you know we just we're a lot we're
starving to death we're hungry these
guys are chasing us with guns you know
blanks of course but we're running I'm
I'm eating Palmetto I mean just ripping
Palms apart trying to get a little piece
of nourishment starving to death we
finally shot a raccoon
and there were seven men 25 year old men
and one little raccoon
and pretty soon we were growling
we were just like a bunch of wolves
and and I the side of me came out of me
that terrified me
is what happens when you go Primal after
day three because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to get some incredible Grant
Cardone inspiration check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there I told my wife when I got with
her I said look I'll do anything for you
except one thing I will not give up on
that drain if I gotta surrender my dream
I'd rather be alone because if I abandon
my dream I'll abandon you I truly
believe that I see so many people man
they give up their dream for the white